je vous présente son bien là
bien monsieur bonjour
chers collègues nous entendons donc
aujourd'hui je me suis Éric Garandeau
directeur des relations gouvernementales
et des politiques publiques de Tik Tok
pour la France Monsieur Garandeau vous
êtes inspecteur des finances vous avez
notamment été conseillé de Jean-Jacques
ayagonise de la Culture et de la
Communication de 2002 à 2004 puis
conseillé du président Nicolas Sarkozy
chargé des dossiers de culture et de
communication entre 2007 et 2010 vous
avez présidé le Centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animé de 2011 à
2013 vous êtes président aujourd'hui de
la société Garandeau Consulting société
de conseil en innovation et ingénierie
de projet dans le domaine culturel
audiovisuel et de la transformation
numérique et vous avez été nommé
directeur des affaires publiques de
TikTok France en septembre 2020 comme
vous le savez notre commission d'enquête
s'intéresse à TikTok sous plusieurs
angles celui de la protection des
données celui des sujets de
désinformation est influence mais aussi
les questions relatives aux effets
psychologiques et sanitaires notamment
chez les enfants nos travaux nous
également donner l'occasion d'aborder
des sujets relatifs au droit d'auteur
sur l'ensemble de ces thèmes monsieur le
rapporteur et les membres de la
commission d'enquête qui le souhaiteront
des questions à vous poser mais je me
dois avant de vous donner la parole pour
un bref propos liminaire si vous le
souhaitez pour nous préciser notamment
vos fonctions au sein de Tik Tok je me
dois de vous rappeler que cette audition
est captée qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et je dois
procéder au formalités d'usage pour les
commissions d'enquête je dois ainsi vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passible
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
434 et 434 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure
je le jure monsieur Garandeau merci vous
avez la parole pour un petit
introduction luminaire et puis après on
passera aux questions de monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs permettez-moi de me présenter
donc je suis directeur des relations aux
institutionnelles et des affaires
publiques de Tik Tok en France j'ai été
recruté le 7 septembre 2020 après plus
de 20 ans de carrière au service de la
culture de l'innovation du numérique
j'ai rejoint Tik Tok car cette
plateforme apporte une nouvelle culture
une nouvelle écriture audiovisuelle
aussi et une nouvelle génération de
cinéastes avec des codes qui leur sont
propres
c'est aussi une nouvelle manière de
diffuser et de partager des oeuvres et
des moments de vie au profit du plus
grand nombre
musique énergie vitesse joie du partage
dialogue des cultures sur la toile du
monde au fond Tic-Toc nous renvoie aux
Années Folles au surréalisme à
l'invention du cinématographe Tik Tok et
la minute lumière au format vertical
alors je vous remercie de cette
opportunité qui nous est donné
d'intervenir devant votre commission
nous avons mobilisé l'ensemble de nos
équipes pour répondre avec la plus
grande attention à tous les
questionnaires qui nous ont été adressés
et cette audition permet de répondre
plus directement à vos attentes et à vos
légitimes interrogations
si je peux présenter l'entreprise en
deux mots
Tik Tok a été créé il y a moins de 6 ans
et appartient au groupe by dance limited
fondé en 2012
sa direction opérationnelle et partager
entre Singapour ou résine notre CIO et
les États-Unis à Los Angeles où sont
localisés les centres de décision sur
les opérations enfin c'est à Dublin en
Europe que notre entité dénommée de
trust and safety confiance et sûreté
dotée de 40000 personnes assure la
sécurité et la protection des
utilisateurs et de leur donner sous le
pilotage global d'un directeur de
nationalité irlandaise
nos priorités n'ont jamais changé
la plus ardente et la sécurité et le
bien-être de nous utilisateurs
ainsi notre politique de traitement des
données vise au plus haut standard de
sécurité elle est fondée sur un principe
clé celui de la souveraineté numérique
qui passe par la localisation des
données au plus près des utilisateurs
avec intervention d'un tiers de
confiance et un recours aux technologies
de protection les plus avancées
la protection des jeunes utilisateurs
âgés de 13 ans et plus est aussi au cœur
de nos préoccupations ce qui passe par
des fonctionnalités restreintes des
contenus adaptés une limitation du temps
d'écran tout cela en étroite
collaboration avec le monde académique
et les associations spécialisées je
pense notamment en France
la deuxième priorité est devrait au
service de nos utilisateurs et de leur
communauté au plus près c'est la raison
pour laquelle Tik Tok développe des
équipes locales dans les différents pays
chargés d'accompagner les créateurs les
institutions les marques Marlène masure
cet après-midi
pourra vous en dire bien davantage
enfin pour ma part je suis naturellement
chargé de veiller à ce que Tik Tok
respecte pleine loi et pleinement les
lois et règlements en vigueur
mais aussi l'écosystème propre à la
France pour que le développement de
l'entreprise soit le plus utile possible
à la société française dans toutes ses
composantes de l'éducation à la santé
publique en passant par l'emploi le
tourisme le soutien aux petites et
moyennes entreprises la contribution à
l'information et au débat public ainsi
que rayonnement international de la
France et de ses territoires
mesdames et messieurs je suis à votre
disposition
merci Monsieur le Directeur nous allons
commencer comme d'habitude par des
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président et merci
Monsieur grindo d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
je ne sais pas s'il en est de même pour
vous mais nous nous étions impatients de
vous entendre
impatient et curieux
et notamment pour la raison suivante
lorsqu'on lit les déclarations des
responsables de Tik Tok pas seulement en
France mais dans tous les TikTok du
monde on se rend ou qu'on se rend sur
les sites de Tik Tok il y a un mot qui
revient sans cesse c'est celui de
transparence
je me permets de citer la page d'accueil
de votre site français chez Tik Tok
notre mission est d'inspirer la
créativité et d'apporter la joie nous
sommes passionnés par le fait de gagner
la confiance de notre communauté en
construisant celle-ci de manière
responsable et équitable et ouverte
et lorsqu'on interroge beaucoup de
personnes nous avons interrogé beaucoup
de monde depuis le début de cette
commission d'enquête que ce soit des
régulateurs des journalistes des
ministres des commissaires européens et
bien d'autres le mot qui revient 99 fois
sur 100 c'est celui d'opacité
on peut le résumer par ce passage d'un
article du Monde que vous me permettrez
de citer du 16 janvier 1923 de 2023
pardon le travail de l'équipe dirigeante
de TikTok en France consiste en réalité
à tenter de nettoyer l'image d'opacité
sans perdre en opacité c'est ainsi qu'en
2020 l'entreprise a recruté eric
Garandeau nommé directeur des affaires
publiques
l'utile entremetteurs joue le monsieur
incendie s'emploie l'évangélisation des
cabinets ministériels et agitent ces
réseaux en tous sens
alors je doute pas que vous ayez
aujourd'hui à cœur de démontrer la
pertinence de la devise de Tik Tok sur
son site et de faire mentir cet article
et l'impression plutôt mitigée qu'il
donne de votre entreprise et que vous
allez nous faire ici une démonstration
de transparence
je voudrais commencer pour que tout le
monde sache de quoi on parle par
l'organigramme de Tik Tok par
l'organisation de Tik Tok France
cette organigramme vous ne l'avez fait
parvenir
et même de façon détaillée
il y manque juste une personne dans
cette organigramme c'est ce c'est la
présidente de Tik Tok France
ça nous a un peu surpris c'est un peu
comme si on vendait l'organigramme de
Facebook et que il y avait pas monsieur
Zuckerberg
alors cette évidemment nous avons pris
d'autres renseignements du côté de Bercy
du côté du tribunal du commerce et nous
nous sommes rendus compte que la
présidente de tikloque France
c'est-à-dire celle qui a signé qui a
déposé les statuts qui étaient qui a
déposé au tribunal de commerce qui
enregistrait s'appelle madame Zao Tian
c'est une chinoise une chinoise de Chine
pas une chinoise de France
qui d'ailleurs
a fait ses études
célèbre académie diplomatique de Pékin
qui forment les diplomates pas mal de
cadres et puis tout ce qui est para
diplomatique si je peux dire
et
ma première question c'est si vous le
permettez c'est je trouve un peu dommage
de ne pas avoir joué à cette
organigramme la personne qui dirige
juridiquement Tik Tok France qui est
Madame Zaho Tian
monsieur le rapporteur
vous étiez une autre entreprise et son
président le président de Tik Tok et
connu il s'agit de Monsieur chaud
chouchou donc il est tout à fait connu
et il présente régulièrement
l'entreprise s'agissant de Tik Tok SAS
Tik Tok en France nous vous avez en
transmis l'organigramme qui correspond à
l'activité à la réalité de l'activité et
de l'organisation de Tik Tok en France
la plupart des entreprises de la tech y
compris certainement celles que vous
citiez ont des filiales dans tous les
pays du monde et pour des raisons
j'allais dire de faciliter quand vous
devez contenir une croissance très
rapide créer des filiales dans le monde
entier la facilité c'est de nommer la
même personne à la tête d'un grand
nombre de filiales pour des raisons
effectivement juridiques puisqu'il faut
avoir un président dans chaque filiale
mais ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
de responsabilité opérationnelle
a-t-elle enseigne que je n'ai jamais
rencontré cette personne
je crois d'ailleurs qu'elle est plutôt
canadienne en tout cas de nationalité
canadiennes il me semble
je crois qu'à l'opèrent sur des sujets
de d'éthique et de d'anthologie mais
absolument pas en France et donc nous
n'avons jamais rencontré donc la réalité
de l'organisation de l'entreprise c'est
je pense cela qui vous intéresse c'est
que nous sommes organisés en différentes
directions
et que chaque responsable de Paul donc
moi même pour ceux qui concerne les
relations institutionnelles Marlène
masure que vous allez interroger cet
après-midi pour ceux qui ont tiens la
direction des opérations et des contenus
nous répondons à supérieur
hiérarchique si on peut dire qui se
trouve être à Londres puisque Tik Tok UK
et la structure assez peu notre maison
mère européenne et donc de même que moi
je réponds à Théo Bertram vice-président
en charge des affaires publiques au
niveau européen de même Marlène masure
répond à rich waterworth qui est
directeur général en charge des contenus
et des opérations pour toute l'Europe et
c'est ainsi que nous fonctionnons et
nous avons un troisième pôle que vous
avez bien vu aussi le pôle Global
Business Services qui travaille pour le
compte d'une troisième division
également situé à Londres à TikTok UK
donc en fait
la personne que vous citiez n'a
absolument aucun rôle opérationnel dans
l'entreprise et nous ne l'avons jamais
rencontré
je ne l'ai jamais rencontré je peux
parler pour moi-même alors une petite
précision vous dites que madame
zaoutienne est canadienne comme beaucoup
de Chinois et pour des raisons diverses
pris une autre nationalité c'est
toujours plus prudent mais j'ai les
Chinoises là aussi la nationalité
canadienne
c'est une première précision vous
comprenez bien que lorsque nous avons
envoyé le questionnaire nous vous avons
demandé un certain nombre de
renseignements sur l'actionnariat etc
d'ailleurs question que sur lesquelles
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui de réponse
mais
que pour nous ce qui est important c'est
tout ça autant le juridique que
l'opérationnel et que nous souhaitions
avoir l'ensemble de l'organigramme de
Tik Tok et qu'il a fallu le chercher
ailleurs
je dois vous dire d'ailleurs que on
était un peu surpris de constater que
Tik Tok France dans le chiffre
d'affaires était de 29 millions d'euros
l'an dernier du doublé au triplé cette
année est une société simplifiée à
actionnaire unique
c'est assez peu fréquent avec quand on
parle de somme de ce montant
le budget de ce montant et donc
juridiquement madame zaoutienne est la
seule habilité à pouvoir prendre toute
décision du genre vendre de la société
acquisition d'autres sociétés fusion etc
et donc elle n'est peut-être pas
opérationnelle mais sur le plan du
devenir de l'entreprise elle joue un
rôle joue un rôle majeur
alors nous avons invité
vous le savez madame zaoutienne à nous
rencontrer ainsi que trois autres
dirigeants de Tik Tok monsieur aussi
[Musique]
ils nous ont pas répondu encore je ne
sais pas s'ils ont le temps de venir
nous voir mais effectivement je
comprends que Madame madame zaoutienne
n'est pas le temps de venir nous voir
parce qu'elle fait beaucoup d'autres
choses d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous avez
dit c'est quand même un peu dommage
qu'elle ne vienne pas visiter la France
en étant président directeur général de
Tik Tok France mais enfin bon
elle est également présidente de tik
Tokyo
elle est également au bord de Tik Tok
Australie
mais elle était également
vice-présidente
alors ça ça pose un problème parce que
je crois que c'est un secret pour
personne
vous essayez
désespérément de répondre à l'accusation
permanente que Tik Tok est une société
chinoise ou en tout cas une société où
les le centre de décision se situe en
Chine avec une influence du PC chinois
dans ces instances dirigeantes et vous
dites comme d'ailleurs tous les
présidents ou les directeurs de Tik Tok
en
Occident nous n'avons rien à voir avec
la Chine les entités sont séparées by
Dance est ok immense TikTok est
osé
et nous n'avons rien à voir avec Do Yin
qui est je le précise parce que ça a
tellement changé au cours des années
précédentes que c'est un véritable entre
lac de de société qui est le nouveau nom
de bayden The Shin puisque auparavant
tout yaourt est une filiale de
bains c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui de
douiller
alors quand vous nous expliquez qu'il
n'y a aucun lien entre
TikTok France contre les TikTok
occidentaux et les entités chinoises je
me permets de vous donner quand on a la
vice-présidente de tout Yao fondé
pardon madame
et vice-présidente depuis 2015 sont si
sur son site internet il y a quelques
temps elle a posté sur son sapage
LinkedIn elle a posté le fait qu'elle
était la puis 8 ans et 3 mois avec un
très fier
je vois pas comment on peut dire dans
ces conditions
que on n'a pas de lien avec la partie
chinoise de by dance
monsieur le rapporteur je pense que il
est peut-être utile pour pour
l'auditoire de rappeler l'organisation
du groupe body dance comme vous l'avez
fait rapidement parce que en matière de
d'organisation juridique du groupe il y
a bien une séparation totale entre Tik
Tok et d'autres entités opérants en
Chine donc ce qui est important de voir
c'est que by dance limited qui est donc
la maison mère
qui est effectivement immatriculée dans
un territoire britannique d'outre-mer
détient à 100% Tik Tok Limited et
qu'ensuite Tic-Toc limited va avoir des
filiales dans les différents territoires
aux États-Unis et en Europe en Europe
nous avons donc Tik Tok UK et Tik Tok
Irlande TikTok Irlande c'est l'entité
qui va être en charge de opérer la
plateforme d'avoir des relations avec
les utilisateurs et les autorités de
régulation tout ce qui concerne
l'application du rgpd par exemple du DSA
c'est Tik Tok Irlande Tik Tok UK out
qu'elle opère la plateforme pour les
citoyens britanniques est aussi notre
entité maison mère pour l'Europe dont
Tik Tok SAS France est aussi la filiale
donc vous voyez quand en termes
d'organisation de verticale du haut en
bas donc de by dance limited jusqu'à
TikTok SAS on a bien une chaîne qui est
entièrement soumise un droit qui est qui
n'est pas un droit chinois qui est un
droit
conforme dans les différents entités
dans lesquelles c'est ces entités
opèrent mais donc vous n'avez aucun lien
avec la Chine le lien il se fait comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure au niveau
de Douine Douine est une filiale de Bike
dance et dowin ensuite détient d'autres
filiales qui opèrent en Chine mais les
deux sont totalement détachés
s'agissant je reviens de de la
présidente de Tik Tok SAS
comme c'est l'usage dans un grand nombre
de d'entreprises technologiques
d'entreprises qui sont présentes dans un
grand nombre de pays dans plus de 80
pays
il est très usuel que les filiales
soient créés j'allais dire à l'appel en
même on en crée des dizaines en même
temps on est obligé et dans ce cas là
par facilité c'est la même personne qui
est présidente de chaque filiale mais ça
l'entraîne aucun lien opérationnel comme
je vous l'indiquais nous n'avons jamais
en tout cas moi je n'ai jamais vu cette
personne ni à l'occasion de mon
recrutement ni par la suite j'ai été
recruté par Monsieur théobert tram
rich Waterworks que je citais tout à
l'heure puis par le CEO qui était à
l'époque américain qui s'appelait Kevin
Meyer et cette personne n'est jamais
intervenue et je n'ai jamais vu avoir la
moindre responsabilité dans Tik Tok SAS
quand vous dites que vous ne la voyez
pas avoir la moindre responsabilité je
vous ai quand même indiqué tout à
l'heure qu'elle avait tous les pouvoirs
et peut-être la chaîne à travers la
chaîne de que vous ne nous avait indiqué
mais tous les pouvoirs sur l'avenir de
Tik Tok sur l'avenir juridique de Tik
Tok
elle peut demain décider de vendre la
société de la dissoudre etc elle est
actionnaires unique donc je comprends
qu'elle n'ayez jamais vu je le regrette
d'ailleurs mais
elle a des fonctions juridiquement
extrêmement importantes et c'est ça qui
des fonctions sur le contrôle juridique
de la société et par ailleurs vous
m'avez parlé du rôle de l'enchaînement
vertical des sociétés
mais là moi je vous parle de
l'horizontalité cette personne vous
essayez désespérément depuis trois ans
depuis que vous êtes
quelques problèmes aux États-Unis et
désormais en Europe avec l'interdiction
de l'application Tik Tok sur les
smartphones des fonctionnaires vous
essayez des Espérants je le comprends de
dire qu'il n'y a aucun lien entre voilà
entre les deux entités
on verra tout à l'heure d'ailleurs en ce
qui concerne l'opérationnel les
algorithmes etc s'il n'y a vraiment
aucun lien mais vous nous dit qu'il n'y
a aucun lien juridique et nous nous
retrouvons avec une personne qui a des
responsabilités juridiques aussi bien en
Chine
qu'en France ou que dans d'autres pays
vous comprenez bien que ça pose un
problème quand même et que le discours
qui consiste à dire on a on a aucun lien
il est quand même difficile à tenir
monsieur le rapporteur vous disiez tout
à l'heure l'actionnariat Tik Tok SAS est
détenu par Tik Tok
UK qui est lui-même détenu par Tik Tok
limited qui lui-même détenu par bidens
limited nous avons un CIO qui est
Monsieur chouchou
c'est lui le CEO de Tik Tok et ensuite
vous avez des chaînes opérationnelles
qui redescendent avec d'un côté les
relations publiques le marketing
les fonctions commerciales et tout cela
redescend jusqu'à jusqu'à la France donc
c'est cela la chaîne du pouvoir la
chaîne hiérarchique et c'est ainsi que
notre groupe est organisé la fonction de
présidente est une fonction purement
formelle elle n'a pas de elle n'a aucun
aucune conséquence opérationnelle
on est bien d'accord
elle n'a pas de conséquence dans la
manière dont l'entreprise dans le groupe
est dirigé et je veux peut-être aussi
rajouter quelque chose c'est que
indépendamment de cette organisation
juridique nous avons évidemment mis en
place toute une série de contrôles s'il
s'agit je comprends que la préoccupation
légitime porte sur la sécurité des
données des utilisateurs notamment des
utilisateurs européens et bien sachez
que nous avons aussi mis en place de
manière technique des systèmes qui
permettent d'éviter toute forme
d'intrusion d'ingérence et
cela passe notamment par le projet que
vous connaissez je pense le projet
Clover qui consiste à créer en Europe
des centres de données qui seront
sécurisés par une entité tierce qui ne
sera pas Tik Tok mais qui sera une
entité européenne
et de manière à ce que les données des
utilisateurs européens soient pleinement
protégées c'est un investissement d'un
milliard 200 millions d'euros par an et
qui précisément à éviter
non seulement toute critique mais tout
risque d'intrusion non désirée nous
mettons aussi en place des des contrôles
de sécurité de manière à ce que un
nombre limité de personnes est accès à
ces centres de données et de manière à
ce que toute accès extérieur soit aussi
le minimum rendu au minimum possible
c'est à dire le minimum qui consiste à
assurer le fonctionnement de la
plateforme
nous recourons aussi comme je disais
dans l'Introduction à des technologies
de protection les plus avancées en
matière d'inscription en matière
d'anonymisation de pseudonyme
pseudonymisation des données
d'agrégation pour aussi éviter tout
risque donc voilà c'est important de
mentionner d'une part l'organisation du
groupe qui encore une fois n'a que des
entités de droits international et qui
n'est jamais soumis aux droits chinois
et ensuite un système technique
robuste et en même temps sophistiqué
très avancé et enfin comme je pense que
vous avez aussi un souci légitime sur la
les contenus qui peuvent circuler sur la
plateforme nous avons cette entité trust
intellective qui comme je le disais est
dirigée par un irlandais en Irlande
40000 personnes qui sont évidemment
répartis aussi dans d'autres pays
notamment à Singapour et aux États-Unis
et cette entité va être en charge de
faire respecter les règles
communautaires de Tik Tok et ses règles
interdisent toute tentative de
désinformation de manipulation de
l'opinion de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité d'une élection et vous savez
donc un très grand nombre de modérateurs
qui vont intervenir ainsi que des tiers
de confiance l'AFP pour faire en sorte
que il n'est pas assez risque là donc
vous voyez la question que vous posez
c'est de la réponse que nous apportons
c'est que quel que soit la nationalité
des personnes le système soit
suffisamment robuste et sophistiqué pour
empêcher tout intrusion tout ingérence
et toute manipulation de l'information
oui je crois qu'on parle pas exactement
la même langue je vous parle juridique
vous me répondez opérationnel je suis
tout à fait prêt à entendre des choses
sur l'opérationnel et c'est ce que nous
allons voir tout à l'heure mais pour le
moment je commence par le juridique et
par l'organisation des sociétés Tik Tok
et by dance vous nous dites vous venez
d'employer les mots aucune de ces
entités n'est jamais soumise au droit
chinois
depuis et je trouve que la présidente
Duke comme celle de tique au France
c'est madame diaothéa qui est une
ressentissante chinoise
avec tout ce qui est toutes les
conséquences puisque c'est par vous avez
peut-être me le dire TikTok sur l'action
narratif mais je vais pas
occupé mais je vais pas en parler tout
de suite
elle peut donc prendre les décisions
juridiques essentielles pour une pour
votre société depuis les deux lois
chinoises de 2017 et 2019 tout citoyen
est toute société chinoise chinoise
est tenu de collaborer avec les
autorités d'ailleurs c'était comme ça
avant mais c'était pas dans le droit
c'était pas encore inscrit
aussi bien en matière de renseignement
qu'en matière que que dans différentes
matières ce sujet a fait couler pas mal
d'angle mais il y a un sujet dont on a
moins parlé c'est que en même temps que
le gouvernement chinois a pris ces deux
décisions c'est de loi qui est désormais
s'applique et qui d'ailleurs dont
Monsieur Jack ma ou Monsieur Jack gaming
on parlera tout à l'heure pourrait sans
doute nous dire pas mal de choses
désagréables
le gouvernement chinois a pris désormais
la décision que son droit s'appliquait
de façon extraterritoriale c'est-à-dire
que tous les Chinois non seulement en
Chine mais même à l'extérieur de la
Chine sont tenus de déférer
dans référé au gouvernement chinois pour
des raisons sur des domaines de
renseignement ou c'est des domaines
différents vous avez donc une société
TikTok SAS France une société TikTok
UK limite présidé par une
présidente chinoise qui a des pouvoirs
dont on a parlé à l'instant et qui
par l'extraterritorialité du droit
chinois aujourd'hui est obligé si le
gouvernement chinois le décide dans une
comment pourrait-on dire d'obéir aux
injonctions du gouvernement chinois je
dis je veux dire que j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment dans ce contexte
où
vous avez ces accusations dont on
parlait tout à l'heure qui ont commencé
aux États-Unis et où vous essayez
désespérément
de
d'expliquer que vous n'avez rien à voir
avec la Chine
je dois dire que je comprends pas
comment vous avez décidé de nommer une
présidente chinoise donc vous dites
qu'elle n'a strictement aucun rôle
opérationnel vous auriez pu aussi me
rendre monsieur Dupont ça aurait été
moins
ennuyeux parce qu'aujourd'hui nous nous
retrouvons avec cette question le
président de chinoise de deux sociétés
et d'autres d'ailleurs
extraterritorialité du droit chinois et
difficulté d'expliquer quand même qu'il
y a pas une certaine présidente de tout
Yao vice-président de tout Yao pardon
donc d'une société chinoise c'est quand
même difficile d'expliquer que cette
dame même si vous l'avez jamais vu et
c'est jamais vu des pieds en France ne
peut pas y compris de Singapour où elle
habite aujourd'hui je crois prendre des
décisions qui seraient
disons pour employer un mot une litote
inspiré par où suggéré par le
gouvernement chinois
monsieur le rapporteur je pense qu'il
faut peut-être revenir vous parler de
donc de juridique donc effectivement en
termes de droits des sociétés comme je
disais il y a un empilement donc Tic-Toc
SAS tik Toky Tik Tok Limited et by dance
donc la pouvoir il descend à 100%
jusqu'en bas depuis le conseil
d'administration de la maison mère qui
est donc Biden Limited et qui n'est
encore une fois pas soumis au droit
chinois qui sont les membres du conseil
d'administration et qui sont d'ailleurs
les apporteurs de capital et au groupe
bin dance vous avez Bill Ford qui
représente générale Atlantique donc un
fond d'investissement institutionnel
américain vous avez Arthur dans le chic
qui représente sous ce qu'est Anna qui
est un autre fond d'investissement
institutionnel américain vous avez
Philippe Lafont qui est français c'est
intéressant de mentionner vous avez un
des cinq membres du Conseil
administration de bydenski et français
et qui
intervient au nom de quoi tu es qui est
son fonds d'investissement et puis vous
avez 1000 chaînes qui intervient au nom
de
séquoia qui est un autre fond dans
l'investissement et enfin rubollyang qui
est le président de by dance donc c'est
là qui est le pouvoir de by dance qui
comme j'expliquais descend jusqu'en bas
jusqu'à Tik Tok SAS
donc vous voyez bien je pense que
c'est personne et ses entités qui
représentent 60% aujourd'hui du capital
de by dance ce sont eux qui exercent le
pouvoir et ensuite pouvoir redescendre
jusqu'à la filiale pour être exhaustif
20% du capital à partir au fondateurs
qui est donc
et puis 20% restants appartiennent aux
salariés du groupe ainsi qu'à des petits
actionnaires donc voilà je pense que
c'est ça la réalité de pouvoir qui est
exercée et ensuite le fait qu'il y ait
tel ou telle personne dans les filiales
encore une fois c'est quelque chose qui
se fait dans la plupart des des
entreprises multinationales qui pour des
raisons de facilité et parce que
effectivement le droit l'oblige dans
chaque pays ont des personnes qui sont
souvent les mêmes personnes mais qui
n'ont absolument aucun rôle opérationnel
merci de cette de cette réponse mais qui
ne à mon avis ne correspond pas vraiment
à la question alors si vous voulez que
je réponde peut-être à la question de la
nationalité puisque
et la question d'extraterriturier du du
de les lois chinoises tout ce que nous
avons mis en place vice précisément à
éviter la moindre critique le moindre
risque quel que soit la nationalité des
personnes de quelques gouvernements que
ce soit de quelques nationalités que ce
soit nous mettons en place un système
qui permet par son intégrité par sa
robustesse par le fait que nous avons
des tirs de confiance qui vont assurer
la cybersécurité de ces centres de
données
par le fait que nous avons de très
grandes équipes de modérateurs des
contenus qui interviennent encore une
fois dans toutes les langues ils
interviennent dans plus de 70 langues
nous avons 600 modérateurs par exemple
en langue française donc toutes ces
mesures sont faites pour que quel que
soit la nationalité quelle que soit le
gouvernement nous n'ayons pas de risque
d'intrusion de risques de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité de la plateforme
pour nous c'est cela qui est vraiment
important et nous sommes l'entreprise je
pense la plus avancée une des plus
avancées en la matière le fait de
décider d'investir un milliard 500
millions de dollars aux États-Unis pour
construire des centres de données
sécurisés et par Oracle donc puisque ces
données sont même opérées directement
par Oracle dans une entité dédiée qui
s'appelle usds avec 1000 personnes
justement de américaine qui
interviennent le fait que nous ayons à
la fois Oracle et un tiers de confiance
supplémentaire qui valide chaque
modification du code source chaque
actualisation du code de Tik Tok
lorsqu'il est envoyé dans les magasins
d'applications
dans les App Store et vérifier à la fois
par Oracle et par ce deuxième tiers de
confiance donc tout cela assure
l'impossibilité pour quiconque quel que
soit sa nationalité
fut-elle chinoise de pouvoir porter
atteinte à ce dispositif et d'ailleurs
les utilisateurs européens bénéficient
de ce système puisque c'est la même
application c'est le même code source en
fait qui est injecté aux États-Unis qui
permet à tout un chacun de télécharger
Tik Tok dans le monde entier et c'est ce
projet cette démarche que nous sommes en
train aussi d'appliquer en Europe à
travers le projet avec lover nous avons
construit un premier Data Center à
Dublin nous en avons construit nous en
construisons un deuxième vous ne l'avez
déjà dit et puis ce n'est pas vraiment
ma question vous comprenez si vous me
permettez je comprends enfin j'essaie de
répondre à votre légitimateur
en montrant que c'est la robustesse d'un
système c'est le fait de passer par des
tiers de confiance qui ne sont pas Tik
Tok et qui pourront justement vous
apporter cette assurance de la même
façon si nous soumettons ce dispositif
avec des centres données des construit
en Europe qui sont sécurisés par un
tiers de confiance européen si nous
demandons à Annecy de pouvoir aussi
vérifier auditer ce dispositif c'est je
pense la meilleure façon de répondre à
cette légitime préoccupation et vous
parlez de la Chine mais on peut parler
d'autres pays la Chine n'est pas le seul
pays qui peut avoir envie de faire des
intrusions lorsqu'il y a eu la guerre en
Ukraine nous avons aussi pris des
mesures très fortes nous avons recruté
des modérateurs dans les deux langues
ukrainiens et russes pour pouvoir nous
assurer que personne ne porterait
atteinte à l'intégrité de la plateforme
ou ne diffuserait des fausses
informations nous avons d'ailleurs été
le la première plateforme à interdire
l'accès à
Spoutnik et à rue Châteaudun donc on a
on a même labell les comptes de médias
détenus par des états vous voyez qu'ils
soient chinois russe ou de toute
nationalité pour que nos utilisateurs
sachent que lorsqu'ils regardent un
compte contre les par un état qu'il
sache ce que ça veut dire et qui puisse
contrôler vérifier avec des sources
d'information on va dire plus
indépendantes donc nous faisons ce
travail permanent
pour nous améliorer on va venir aux
questions de de contrôle de
l'information etc on va essayer de
Serrier les deux séries les sujets
jusqu'au bout du juridique je vais
essayer de revenir sur la première
partie effectivement si à chaque fois
qu'on parle actionnariat juridique et
tout vous parlez opérationnel l'audition
risque d'être un peu longue
mais effectivement comme le dit le
président les sujets dont vous parlez à
l'instant sont des sujets différents
dont on parlera plus tard
je reviens à ce que vous disiez sur
l'actionnariat puisque vous parlez de
l'actionnariat de by dance caïmans
au passage je voudrais vous poser une
question les
îles Caïmans sont classées deuxième au
classement 2021 des paradis fiscaux du
réseau international pour la justice les
îles Caïmans sont l'un des grands
paradis fiscaux du monde qui abritent
évidemment de nombreuses sociétés
offshore en tant que société écran
se déclarait transparent en établissant
son siège dans le paradis des sociétés
écran
c'est une sorte d'oxymore non
il me semble que votre souci encore une
fois légitime c'est que il n'y ait pas
de pression exercée par un état sur Tik
Tok sur cette plateforme importante et
le fait de n'être mis en Chine ni
d'ailleurs aux États-Unis c'est plutôt
en tout cas de ce point de vue là une
sécurité les îles Caïmans sont un
territoire britannique d'outre-mer
soumis au système de Westminster voilà
j'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
en tout cas il y a pas de pression
fiscale ça c'est certain il me semble
que vous intéresser aux pression
politique mais pour s'agissant de on
peut tout faire
de la fiscalité on pourra en dire un mot
même si je serai un peu limité par le
secret fiscal mais je serai ravi
d'échanger à ce sujet d'ailleurs vous
avez pris des précautions aussi aux
États-Unis puisque Tik Tok États-Unis
est enregistré au 2 la Loire qui est
comme chacun sait
à peu près le même paradis fiscal que
les îles Caïmans mais c'est pour moi
relativement secondaire alors vous nous
parliez de l'actionnariat
et cette actionnariat vous le vous le
brandissez en tout cas Tik Tok le
États-Unis ou by dance pardon le brandit
sur son site avec tous les tous les
grands fonds d'investissement qui sont
sécurisent la chose évidemment qui ont
investi des milliards de dollars dans
dans le
dans l'entreprise
mais
et vous nous avez cité les membres du
bord et notamment monsieur Roubaud Lyon
et Monsieur Nilsen qui je vous signale
au passage ont le même problème que
Madame zaoutien du point du juridique
c'est qu'ils sont chinois et qu'avec
l'explorateur de réalité il risque un
jour ou l'autre d'avoir quelques
contacts de la part du gouvernement
chinois
donc le président de baitet dance est un
il a de nationalité chinoise
et donc sujet au droit chinois
qui m'intéresse dans l'actionnariat ça
n'est pas le pourcentage des parts
détenus par chacun des actionnaires ce
sont
les droits de vote
comme disait Staline ce qui compte ce
n'est pas les votes c'est qui compte les
votes
Biden ce Cayman est une société
une vie une vallée interestone City
c'est à dire que les droits de vote
ne correspondent pas aux parts des
tenues par les différents actionnaires
et par conséquent alors vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que les fondateurs
avaient 20% du capital
d'abord déjà sur la répartition du
capital
il se trouve que en France Monsieur
jeanming est actionné et bénéficiaire à
26%. c'est ce qui est inscrit au
tribunal de commerce
pourquoi est-ce que monsieur tanguyming
est le seul qui apparaissent auprès du
tribunal de commerce parce que les
bénéficiaires doivent être inscrits à
partir de 25%. mais
les monsieur John gaming ayant 26% est
donc inscrire un commerce il y en a sans
doute mais ils ne sont pas inscrits
j'imagine en remontant la chaîne que si
Monsieur
changing est bénéficiaire à 26% de Tik
Tok SAS France c'est que il est
actionnaire à 26% de
bidons caïman
mais je peux me tromper vous allez nous
allez nous le dire alors moi je voulais
vous le demander si vous pouvez nous
dire d'une part quelle est la part vous
avez commencé à nous le dire en disant
20% mais ce n'est pas tout à fait exact
jusqu'à lui seul monsieur de Jean
gimming à 26% donc et il est pas le seul
fondateur
si vous pouvez nous dire quelle est la
part des fonds d'investissement général
des fondateurs et des salariés et
éventuellement le nom des salariés parce
que c'est pas c'est pas le le
développeur de base qui est qui est dans
le qui est dans le l'actionnariat c'est
évidemment quelques cadres salariés donc
ce serait intéressant de le savoir mais
deuxièmement ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
plus c'est de savoir quelle est la
répartition des droits de vote parce que
c'est
comme ça qu'on prend la décision de
l'entreprise et dans les vies le système
chinois qui est développé depuis
quelques années c'est comme ça que un
certain nombre d'actionnaires de de
Tencent se sont réveillés avec quelques
douleurs quand ils sont rendus compte
que le gouvernement chinois considère
que ces vies n'étaient pas conforme au
droit chinois et que par conséquent il
n'y avait pas elle n'avait pas être
remboursé de l'investissement qu'elles
avaient fait
mais c'est un autre sujet de mais en
tout cas bidons et une veille comme
comme Tencent aux îles Caïmans
d'ailleurs et d'autres donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire qui comment est
réparti comment sont répartis des droits
de vote au sein de by dance caïman
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une société non cotée donc c'est
ce qui explique que
ne publie pas toutes les données que
publie des sociétés cotées qui sont
elles soumises à des obligations de
publication plus importante
par ailleurs ce sont des données que je
n'ai pas ma possession je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse les partager
publiquement dans cette séance mais je
me permettrai en tout cas de revenir
vers vous
voilà sous forme probablement écrite à
ce sujet
si vous me permettez
nous l'avions déjà demandé dans les
questions écrites
éventuellement si c'est possible bien
entendu mais vous auriez eu le temps de
les demander
[Musique]
je voulais vous poser quelques questions
sur monsieur tsangyming
le fondateur de Tik Tok le fondateur de
binz
qui est donc à ma connaissance en tout
cas selon ce qu'on peut retrouver
actionnaire à 26% de vaidan c'est je ne
sais pas quels sont ces droits de vote
ni ceux de Monsieur rebollion
[Musique]
était le l'actionnaire quasi unique de
Biden Chine
il a
cédé
38 ans 36 ans
brusquement je crois que c'était en 2021
qui était toutes ses fonctions de
direction à bayden Chine qui est devenu
ensuite douillet
au même moment où Jack ma et un certain
nombre d'autres se faisait
le même genre de situation et
visiblement directement inspiré par le
gouvernement chinois mais en ce qui
concerne un gaming je n'en sais rien
et en janvier 2023 monsieur jean-gaming
après avoir donc
quitter toutes ces fonctions
opérationnelles en 2021
à cédé toutes ses parts d'un seul coup
99% de l'entreprise
à une autre société
cette société
qui s'appelle xxq
[Musique]
elle avait été créée 15 jours avant
elle a racheté une entreprise qui va
aujourd'hui quelques centaines de
milliards
puisque douille et l'essentiel Tic-Toc
USA c'est 150 millions de utilisateurs
français 15 ou 20 millions
c'est 700 millions donc c'est là le
principal revenu de de Bin dance
il a cédé sépare
à une société qui s'appelle xxq
et qui était détenu à 55 ans par deux
personnes qui s'appelle monsieur yinping
et Monsieur Lee Ying
en général dans le monde de la tech tout
le monde a une grande visibilité sur des
sites personnels sur Linkedin ou
ailleurs mais ces deux personnes là sont
absolument introuvables sur l'Internet
tout ce qu'on en sait c'est que Monsieur
leasing est un cadre local du PC à
sciamen puisque xxq veut dire que c'est
la ville de Siemen
et si amen c'est
la ville
en Chine dans le fou de géant
dont Monsieur xinking a été
le maire où il a démarré sa carrière
politique dans le Fujian dans les années
88 90
cette société avait un capital je crois
d'environ 150000 euros elle a racheté
une société qui avait je ne connais pas
son capital tel qu'il est estimé mais
enfin qui a une surface de qui se compte
en centaines de millions ou en milliards
de dollars
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
je n'ai pas connaissance de ce que vous
indiquez je n'ai pas commenté ce qui me
semble très loin de
à la fois de mon rôle de directeur des
relations institutionnelle de Tik Tok
France ni même assez loin de ce Tik Tok
en réalité
ce que je sais simplement c'est que
effectivement notre enfin le fondateur
de by dance donc monsieur iminzang a
quitté c'est fonction opérationnelle je
vois même qu'on vous a envoyé le message
qui est qu'il avait pu envoyer à tous
les salariés du groupe à cette occasion
et qui dans lesquelles il indiquait
qu'il souhaitait quitter ses fonctions
opérationnelles qui étaient extrêmement
prenante et que il voulait consacrer son
temps à réfléchir à la stratégie du
groupe puisque c'est un fondateur un
entrepreneur visionnaire et qui et qui
pense au long terme et qui donc voulait
se dégager de la gestion quotidienne de
ce groupe voilà ça c'est ce que je sais
ce que je peux vous dire
après si vous souhaitez qu'on puisse
apporter plus de précisions par écrit
sur ce que vous venez d'indiquer nous le
ferons bien volontiers ça m'intéresse
quand même parce que Monsieur diongaming
il est pas du tout son relation il est
pas du tout resté en Chine et tout il
est toujours aujourd'hui à 26 %
apparemment
actionnaire de Biden Skyland et
peut-être même qu'il a la majorité des
droits de vote je n'en sais rien puisque
cette veille a l'air très très
difficile à ausculter donc ça
effectivement j'aimerais savoir quelle
est la répartition des droits de vote et
que quelle est la part de monsieur John
gaming parce que là on a quand même une
relation avec Tik Tok avec Tik Tok
caïman et avec tous les Tik Tok
UK France etc monsieur John gaming il
avait eu quelques problèmes avec le
Parti communiste chinois lorsqu'il était
PDG de baiden ce Chine devenu Douine et
notamment il était également PDG de tout
Yao dans Madame Tao
est aujourd'hui vice-président
il a eu le malheur de faire un site
parodique un peu genre Canard Enchaîné
ce qui pose assez peu de problèmes en
France mais qui généralement peut
évidemment conduire à quelques
difficultés en Chine et donc il s'est
fait il s'est fait taper sur les doigts
et voilà ce qu'il dit dans une
autocritique qui évidemment lui a été
dictée dans le plus pur style maoïste
auquel on est en train de revenir en
Chine
il n'a fait publiquement bien entendu
sur et sur son site j'exprime mes plus
sincère excuse aux autorités à nos
usagers et à mes collègues depuis que
j'ai reçu hier la note des autorités de
régulation je suis plein de remords et
de culpabilité qui m'ont empêché de
dormir tout Yao fermera définitivement
son application Nyan douanzy et tous ses
comptes notre produit a pris un mauvais
chemin et à proposer un contenu
incompatible avec les valeurs de base du
socialisme
nous n'avons pas été assez attentif et
n'avons pas assimilation sur la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
dans la promotion d'une énergie positive
et la compréhension des principes
corrects qui doivent guider l'opinion
publique en tant que start-up en
développement rapide dans le siège du
XVIIIe congrès national du Parti
communiste chinois nous sommes
pleinement conscients que ce
développement a été permis par ces
terres glorieuses j'exprime mes
remerciements pour cet air j'exprime ma
gratitude pour cette occasion historique
de réforme économique et d'ouverture et
ma gratitude envers ce gouvernement qui
a permis le développement de l'industrie
technologique
et il conclut en prenant des engagements
premièrement renforcer le travail de
construction du parti au sein de
l'entreprise réussir l'éducation de
toute notre équipe quand aux quatre
consciences aux valeurs de base du
socialisme au principe qui guident le
pignon public aux lois et règlement pour
agir vraiment dans le sens de la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
approfondir la coopération avec les
médias officiels augmenter la diffusion
des contenus officiels et s'assurer que
la voix des médias officiels soit reliée
avec force renforcer le système de
responsabilité de la rédaction en chef
corrigé entièrement les déficiences dans
le contrôle des algorithmes et des
ordinateurs dans le contrôle des
algorithmes et des ordinateurs renforcer
les opérations et les contrôles humains
alors monsieur John gaming est
aujourd'hui
actionnaire à 26% de bydens
caïman peut-être décisionnaire en
matière de droit de vote je n'en sais
rien
mais avec Monsieur Roubaud Lyon qui est
le co-fondateur et en 2012 il doit avoir
eu deux sans doute la majorité des
droits de vote ils sont soumises à
l'extraité territorialité du droit
chinois et ils ont été en 2018 je crois
par cette autocritique exprimée leur
volonté de se conformer très strictement
à la loi chinoise et à ce que leur
demanderait le Parti communiste chinois
ça fait un peu tâche dans une société
mondiale comme Biden ce qui est aux îles
Caïman et qui sont et qui est censé ne
pas avoir aucun rapport avec la Chine
monsieur le rapporteur il me semble que
vous évoquez des faits qui se sont
passés en Chine et qui correspondent
l'activité à l'activité de filiales et
même de sous filiales du groupe bidens
en Chine il me semble que
les préoccupations encore une fois
légitimes de votre commission porte sur
Tik Tok et sur l'activité de Tik Tok en
France
d'un point de vue droit des sociétés il
me semble avoir démontré que bidens
étant immatriculé effectivement
oser le caïmans et étant actionnaires à
100% de TikTok limité de lui-même
immatriculé dans les îles Caïmans avec
une chaîne qui redescend jusqu'à Tic-Toc
SAS en France fait que d'un point de vue
juridique il n'y a absolument aucune
possibilité d'avoir des pressions ou des
demandes des interventions de la part du
gouvernement chinois ou de tout entité
chinoise il n'y a aucun pourcentage du
capital de by dance ou de Tik Tok qui
soit détenu par une entité émanant de la
Chine
d'autre part nous publions dans un
rapport de transparence qui est
trimestriel l'ensemble des demandes des
autorités administratives de tous les
pays du monde qui sont effectuées auprès
de Tik Tok voilà donc dès qu'un
gouvernement s'adresse à TikTok demande
communication d'information
dans le cadre de procédure
administratives et judiciaire nous les
publions donc c'est comme ça que nous
savons qu'il a eu 228 demandes
effectuées par la France au premier
semestre 2022 qu'il y en a eu 1150 en
Allemagne il y en a 0 qui émane de la
Chine et pour une raison simple c'est
que nous n'opérons pas en Chine que Tik
Tok ne perd pas en Chine donc il y a
cette étanchéité qui est bien assurée à
la fois dans le droit des sociétés et
qui est assuré aussi par des outils de
transparence et je ne reviens pas
évidemment sur tout le dispositif
technique que nous avons évoqué donc la
Constitution la création avec ses
datacenter protégées avec cette tiers
partie avec ces systèmes de lutte contre
les cyber-intrusions et faites aussi
pour répondre à vos attentes légitimes
pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait aucune
possibilité de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité de Tik Tok même si un
dirigeant de Tik Tok ou de by dance le
demander et c'est d'ailleurs c'est comme
je disais c'est un Irlandais basé en
Irlande qui dirige l'entité trust sensei
donc même dans ce cas où il y aurait une
demande adressée à une importante
personnalité travailler dans le groupe
ce système de sécurité avec ses droits
d'accès permet que ce soit impossible
alors vous nous dites depuis le début de
cette audition vous nous l'avez répété
plusieurs fois Tik Tok n'est pas
disponible en Chine continentale tandis
que douille n'est pas disponible en
dehors de la Chine continentale donc il
n'y a aucun rapport
mais vous ne nous dit pas pourquoi
TikTok ne perd pas en Chine continental
Tik Tok ne perd pas en gîte parce qu'il
est interdit en Chine continentale comme
les gafam comme Facebook comme
Twitter
et comme Google etc etc par le
gouvernement
pourquoi ne protestez-vous pas comme les
autres comme les gafams
contre cette interdiction d'un
gouvernement totalitaire cette censure
qui empêche les plateformes qui ne sont
pas chinoises d'intervenir en Chine
si vous êtes totalement indépendant ça
devrait pas vous poser problème mais je
pense que vous devriez pouvoir
protester comme le fond Facebook Google
etc ça sert à rien mais au moins on
proteste et on montre où est le bon
droit alors sur ce sur ce terrain là
comme vous l'avez peut-être constaté
lorsque vous ouvrez l'application TikTok
qui est une application communautaire
c'est à dire que Tik Tok ne produit pas
de contenu c'est ce sont les
utilisateurs qui créent des contenus
vous pouvez voir que si vous allez sur
des hashtags enfin pardon des mots
dièses oui gourd par exemple ce modèle a
été visionné plus de 400 millions de
fois c'est à dire que vous avez des
vidéos qui défendent ces communautés qui
sont tout à fait en accès libre et
partagé sur l'application Tik Tok donc
la liberté d'expression est totale y
compris pour critiquer tel ou tel
gouvernement sauf en Chine Tic-Toc est
présent dans un très grand nombre de
pays et elle est utilisée par des
communautés y compris les communautés
wiggor je sais que vous êtes très
attachés à ce sujet et qui peuvent
s'exprimer librement sur Tik Tok pour
défendre leurs droits et parler de leur
communauté de même que vous avez je
crois auditionné Raphaël Glucksmann il
est pas très longtemps qui lui raconte
aussi sur Tik Tok sur lequel il fait
état de tous ces discours très critiques
sur le gouvernement chinois et il fait
d'ailleurs des très beaux scores donc le
rôle le rôle de Tik Tok si vous me
permettez c'est d'être justement cet
espace de liberté d'expression totale
dans le respect évidemment de la
tolérance d'autrui mais où chacun peut
exprimer ses idées sans aucune forme de
censure
vous êtes directeur des affaires
publiques d'une société
dont la maison mère et Maiden Skyman qui
publie 400 millions de messages ou de
vidéos je ne sais pas sur les ouigo
Chinois
et les seuls qui ne peuvent pas voir
cela
ce sont les Chinois et vous avez dans le
même groupe by dance gamer la société
l'entreprise douille qui est chinoise et
qui bien évidemment est totalement
censuré il n'y a pas seulement les ouigo
il y a la guerre en Ukraine etc
est-ce que vous trouvez normal
d'appartenir à un groupe
ou la société qui dit toute la vérité
qui dit en tout cas tout ce que tout le
monde a le droit de dire et qui parle
librement n'est pas accessible en Chine
et que dans ce même groupe il y a une
société qui est pratiquement la même
avec un algorithme qui a été développé
au départ pratiquement identique et qui
restait très largement identique et qui
est totalement censuré par le
gouvernement chinois
ça vous ne protestez pas
moi je suis fier en tout cas
d'appartenir à une entreprise à une
plateforme qui s'appelle Tik Tok et qui
promeut le dialogue des cultures de
toutes les cultures ou la liberté
d'expression est totale j'aurais été
évidemment très mal à l'aise dans le cas
contraire sans doute que je ne serai pas
là mais justement pour précisément Tik
Tok et cette plateforme qui permet
d'opérer alors en respectant les lois en
vigueur dans chaque pays donc il y a
d'autres pays que la Chine ou parfois ça
peut poser problème mais à chaque fois
nous avons défendu la liberté
d'expression nous avons d'ailleurs
publié un engagement en faveur des
droits de l'homme Tik Tok a publié cet
engagement enfin avoir des droits de
l'homme
qui est donc dans la mesure du possible
à chaque fois qu'il y a une difficulté
nous
maintenant et nous défendons la liberté
d'expression et on peut parler de tout
sujet sur Tik Tok y compris de la de la
Chine
à titre personnel qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la politique du gouvernement
chinois envers les ouigo
si vous m'interrogez à titre personnel
bien entendu que je suis je condamne
toutes les attentes qui peut y avoir
dans au droit de l'homme et pas
seulement Chine dans le monde entier
et on verra les Tibétains
les Tibétains et comme je vous le disais
dans bien d'autres pays il est hélas des
attentes au droit de l'homme et
précisément Tik Tok et cette plateforme
où toutes les ONG peuvent s'exprimer en
toute liberté
on a même je dis ça parce que c'est que
c'était quelque chose d'important pour
vous les décomptes de Médecins sans
frontières qui font des très belles
vidéos comme la Croix-Rouge et qui
permettent justement d'être les voix de
ces de ces libertés et de ces peuples
qui justement aspirent la liberté
et quel est votre réunion personnelle
sur la censure massive exercée par le
gouvernement chinois sur les contenus de
nos sociétés de votre groupe qui
s'appelle douillet il me semble que je
viens avant tout de votre commission
pour parler comme directeur des
relations institutionnelles de Tik Tok
en France pour ce qui concerne la France
oui mais si vous me parlez à titre
personnel oui bien sûr que je considère
que il faut défendre la liberté partout
dans le monde et que c'est justement
l'intérêt de cette plateforme qui
s'appelle Tik Tok c'est de permettre ce
dialogue des cultures cette meilleure
compréhension qui est si nécessaire
aujourd'hui au moment où les tensions
grandissent entre les entre les peuples
et les continents
merci est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quelle est la part de Tik Tok France
dans les bénéfices de Tik Tok caïman
alors
si vous me permettez sur ces tous ces
sujets comme Tik Tok et n'est pas une
entreprise côté il se
sont préférable de pouvoir échanger par
un par écrit en tout cas dans un cadre
confidentiel sur les données qui sont
les données effectivement économiques ou
fiscales
si vous ne le permettez
bien j'en ai terminé avec la première
partie peut-être que si comme ça semble
devoir durer longtemps peut-être que on
pourrait passer et puis ensuite
on est sur des sujets qui sont recreusés
après on essaiera de de recadrer tout ça
avant de passer la parole à l'ancien
j'aurais une ou deux questions courtes
je suis pas spécialiste de comment dire
du positionnement politique des
îles Caïmans en faveur du développement
du numérique donc je mesure mal la
raison de la domiciliation aux îles
Kaliman mais pour ce qui est de
l'entité en Irlande pourquoi l'Irlande
on aurait été ravi en France d'avoir les
40000 personnes
ça je n'ai pas de commentaires
particuliers à faire si sinon que
l'Irlande c'est vrai elle est choisie
pour par un grand nombre d'entreprises
de technologie pour pour s'installer
voilà mais en tout cas
je pense que c'est intéressant de savoir
qu'il y a aussi un bureau en France avec
plus de 200 salariés aujourd'hui qui a
grandi très vite puisque quand j'étais
recruté il y avait au moment de mes
entretiens de recrutement on était
quatre puis 20 et là on est plus de 200
donc je pense qu'il y a quand même un
intérêt fort à développer une présence
en France
voilà parce que j'allais dire
peut-être qu'une question aussi de
fiscalité sans faire de procès
d'intention parce qu'on n'est pas là
pour faire des procès mais peut-être une
question de fiscalité et de degré
d'exigence de la CNIL entre guillemets
irlandaise mais
ça chacun pourra pourra se faire son
idée pour ne pas revenir dessus par
rapport à la présentation initiale que
vous avez tenu à faire sur votre rôle au
sein de Tik Tok SS est-ce que je peux
vous demander puisque vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire et que cette importance
aussi pour nous de comprendre comment
sont utilisés les compétences et les
ressources de la fonction publique
française
à quel moment avez-vous eu votre premier
contact avec by dance
monsieur le Président donc je suis
fonctionnaire évidemment en
disponibilité c'est-à-dire je me suis un
jeu bien compris on l'a dit au départ
mais justement à quel moment avez-vous
votre premier contact avec
en mars 2020 je pense
mars ou avril 2020 je pense dans vos
fonctions antérieures vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion de traiter avec
la réponse est clair
vos fonctions aujourd'hui en tant que
directeur des affaires publiques
etes-vous salarié de Tik Tok SS ou
êtes-vous prestataire de Tik Tok les 16
dans la mesure où dans la présentation
nous avons fait et qui avait l'air de
vous convenir vous êtes également le
patron d'une d'une entreprise de
l'enseigne non alors je suis salarié
effectivement je suis salarié à plein
temps de Tik Tok SAS d'accord et votre
votre entreprise de conseil n'est pas
prestataire non non pas absolument pas
non encore et vous n'êtes pas
prestataire non plus pour d'autres
entités Tik Tok dans d'autres pays
européens absolument pas non non non
vraiment j'exerce la totalité de mon
activité pour Tik Tok très bien je vous
remercie madame Rossignol ensuite
j'avais madame Morin de sayi qui avait
vu la main monsieur gatolin monsieur
Cardon et après on repassera monsieur
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
j'ai quatre questions j'ai fait une par
une où je les groupes
non comme vous voulez président
ma première monsieur d'abord je connais
les règles de Tik Tok concernant la
lutte contre la pornographie les news
etc je crois savoir que votre vos outils
pour tenir vos engagements sont
essentiellement des algorithmes et non
pas et en plus grande proportion des
algorithmes que des ressources humaines
la preuve en est qu'il vous arrive de
passer complètement à côté d'un certain
nombre de diffusion vous avez eu une
affaire comme ça il y a quelques mois
avec les dicks qui sont propagés sur Tik
Tok pendant plusieurs jours et malgré
des signalements et qui ont adminymat
révélé que certaines choses pouvaient
échapper à vos algorithmes vous je sais
que vous avez aussi signé la Charte
européenne contre le développement de la
haine en ligne ma première question est
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
recruter des moyens humains qui sont
plus efficaces et dans quelle proportion
ou est-ce que vous continuez de faire
confiance aux algorithmes pour lutter
contre la haine en ligne ou encore
d'autres
attractions d'autres formes
d'attractivité qui vous sont reprochés
qui concernent l'apologie de la maigreur
les mutilations etc qui circulent
puisque comme vous le dites il n'y a pas
de vidéo Tik Tok il n'y a que des vidéos
que les gens mettent sur TikTok ça c'est
ma première question concerne les
ressources humaines la dernière question
est lié à celle là
quels sont les moyens que vous entendez
mettre en place ou que vous mettez déjà
en place et avec quel résultat pour
lutter contre le grooming
pédopornographique
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que le
grooming bendo-bornographique consiste
qui consiste à utiliser les réseaux
sociaux pour entrer en contact avec des
mineurs et les attirer sur d'autres
sites et qui est un des sujets après mes
deux autres questions sont un peu moins
technique peut-être
vous avez été au service de l'État
vous avez été Président du CNC c'est ça
j'ai bien entendu je j'imagine donc à ce
moment là dans votre parcours vous aviez
une certaine idée de ce que de ce que
sont les politiques culturelles de leurs
fonctions et une certaine idée de
l'accès à la culture est-ce que vous
considérez qu'aujourd'hui en tant que
chargé des affaires publiques de Tik Tok
votre activité est cohérente avec ce que
vous avez pu promouvoir un moment donné
en gros est-ce que le fait d'être dans
les affaires publiques d'une société
dont tout le monde connaît la toxicité
par la méthode des algorithmes
ces algorithmes qui contribuent à
enfermer des jeunes dans une
consommation
d'un volume de vidéo que aucune autre
plateforme n'atteint dans les mêmes à
même rapidité qui consiste les enfermés
ou les conduire dans des sujets qui sont
supposés être leur sujet d'intérêt
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est comme
ça que vous contribuez à former des
citoyens ou est-ce que vous avez renoncé
à former des citoyens et ma dernière
question vous venez de nous dire que
vous êtes en disponibilité de la haute
fonction publique
pourquoi vous ne démissionnez pas est-ce
que vous pensez que les fonctions que
vous
occupez actuellement sont compatibles
avec un retour un jour dans la fonction
publique et au service de l'État
merci
donc quatre questions importantes alors
la première sur les ressources humaines
ce qui est important c'est de combiner
au mieux compte tenu des flux parce que
c'est évidemment une très grande
quantité de vidéos qui sont postées
chaque jour en France et dans le monde
entier donc là toute la question est de
combiner au mieux l'intelligence
artificielle ce qu'on appelle le machine
learning c'est à dire des algorithmes
qui effectivement vont apprendre de
mieux en mieux à détecter des images qui
peuvent être des images pornographiques
au pédopornographiques pour reprendre
vos centres d'intérêt ou des images de
nudité de des mots d'insultes tout ce
qui est en ligne extrémisme
nazisme racisme etc donc c'est ces
algorithmes vont quand même déjà faire
une grosse partie du travail et c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs que
97% des contenus qui sont retirés sur
Tik Tok le son de manière proactive
c'est à dire sans sans aucun signalement
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle 88%
de ces contenus sont retirés avant 24
heures
et donc c'est cette démarche évidemment
se perfectionne avec des ressources
d'intelligence artificielle récemment un
lanceur d'alerte signalait que c'est
effectivement la manière dont sont
conçus ces algorithmes c'est
que qui permet de s'assurer que ces
contenus seront retirés très rapidement
et qui ne reviendront pas sur la
plateforme et ensuite vous avez raison
il y a aussi le travail humain quand
vous avez une vidéo avec une croix
gammée ça peut être une vidéo néonazi ça
peut être une vidéo du Mémorial de la
Shoah que nous sommes très heureux
d'avoir accueilli sur la plateforme pour
faire de la pédagogie sur la Shoah et la
lutte contre le néonazisme donc c'est
pour ça que nous avons des modérateurs
humains et quand je citais 40000
personnes c'est ça fait la taille de je
crois peut-être j'ai pas la ville
d'Angoulême quelque chose comme ça c'est
c'est massif ce sont des effectifs très
nombreux 40 000 personnes et nous en
avons donc je disais à peu près 600 en
langue française et qui vont me faire
que
regarder des contenus en langue
française et faire des interprétations
plus fines des choses là où il y a
parfois des ou c'est le sujet est un peu
plus difficile c'est le harcèlement
parce que le harcèlement est un sujet
sur lequel on a besoin d'avoir un
contexte et on a des vidéos qui peuvent
être anodines et quand en réalité sont
des vidéos de harcèlement il faut
connaître le contexte c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons des signes à
l'heure de confiance il enfance stop
fisha point de contact ce sont des
organisations qui sont spécialisées dans
la détection de ces contenus on est même
en train de d'insérer le 30 18 qui est
le numéro de en France puisqu'on sait
que parfois les jeunes ils préfèrent
chatter ils préfèrent échanger
textuellement pour parler de leurs
problèmes voilà on est en train
d'intégrer ça dans Tik Tok pour pouvoir
aussi faire de la détection j'allais
dire anticiper de la prévention c'est
extrêmement important donc on a une
chaîne de signalement avec des tiers de
confiance qui permet d'être encore plus
rapide
sur la la lutte contre la
pédopornographie donc vous le rappeliez
nous sommes membres d'un grand nombre
d'associations de coalition on est
membre par exemple de huit protect qui
est la plus grande alliance
multisectorielle pour lutter contre
l'exploitation sexuelle des enfants en
ligne
ce qui est très important de noter là
aussi pour la prévention c'est que quand
vous avez des jeunes et notamment des
très jeunes c'est à dire de 13 à 18 ans
des mineurs quand ils ont entre 13 et 15
ans
et bien ils n'ont pas de messagerie par
exemple pas de messagerie pas de
possibilité d'envoyer des messages leur
compte est privé par défaut ils peuvent
pas télécharger de vidéos ils peuvent
pas profiter de certaines
fonctionnalités comme les duos les
stitchs etc
et évidemment on encourage très
fortement
à l'acouplage avec le fait le Family
Perrine donc le contrôle parental
l'assistance aux familles qui permet
ensuite y compris de déterminer le temps
d'écran on sait que c'est un sujet aussi
de
préoccupation donc
d'ailleurs maintenant depuis quelques
mois le temps d'écran est limité à 60
minutes par défaut vous verrez peut-être
en revenir dessus voilà donc on veille
aussi à ce que des fonctionnalités
soient restreintes et même entre 16 et
18 ans
la messagerie sera aussi désactivé par
défaut on sait que c'est par la
messagerie que parfois les connexions se
font et d'ailleurs même si la messagerie
est activée le jeune ne pourra pas
envoyer de pièces jointes on peut pas
envoyer de pièces jointes sur Tik Tok
donc ça aussi ça évite le chantage au
nude etc voilà donc ça ça fait partie
des éléments de réponse sur l'accès à la
culture
je le disais presque en introduction
c'est à dire que ça m'a intéressé de
venir chez Tik Tok parce
qu'effectivement je suis passionné de
culture et je suis passionné de
transmission culturelle et je retrouve à
la fois chez Tik Tok
une nouvelle génération de créateurs
qui justement utilise ces outils très
nouveau très perfectionnés même des
filtres des effets en été augmentés
et donc on a des vrais cinéastes qui
émergent sur la plateforme Tik Tok c'est
pas pour rien d'ailleurs qu'on a fait
une compétition internationale de de
films Tik Tok le format vertical conduit
à une nouvelle écriture donc c'est
intéressant d'un point de vue artistique
on sait souvent le médium et le médium
et le message
et vous parlez de toxicité
nous avons engagé des travaux importants
pour que les algorithmes soient source
de découverte
évidemment on enferme jamais les gens
dans des bulles ce qui serait ce qui
serait très très mauvais
et donc l'algorithme vise au contraire à
stimuler l'utilisateur en lui proposant
des choses qui ne sont pas forcément
dans ces préférences exprimées ou dans
son historique de parcours sur
l'application donc il y a une fonction
de test de voilà de contenu nouveau si
vous avez aimé je sais pas la
gastronomie coréenne peut-être que vous
irez les séries coréennes parfois ce
sont même des associations qui sont
encore moins évidentes mais l'algorithme
avec les informations qu'il a pu générer
test en tout cas des nouvelles des
nouveaux contenus pour voir si vous
allez adhérer à ces contenus on veille à
ce que vous n'ayez jamais dans le fil
pour toi deux vidéos du même créateur ou
deux vidéos du même son on veille aussi
est-ce que les contenus qui sont
autorisés mais qui dont la consommation
excessive des mêmes contenus peut
entraîner justement des problèmes si
vous regardez que des vidéos avec des
régimes amincissants c'est pas bon si
vous regardez que des vidéos de fitness
c'est pas bon non plus donc ce type de
produit enfin de pardon de contenu on
veille aussi à ce qui ne soit pas fourni
en trop grande quantité dans un même
flux pour que justement les gens qui ont
tendance à aller vers des pratiques un
peu extrême ben ne soit pas encouragés à
le faire et voir même parfois on leur
propose des ressources on leur dit mais
voilà vous avez tapé ce mot ce mot
suicide par exemple évidemment non
seulement montre pas de vidéo de suicide
mais en plus on va vous emmener vers
une page qui va vous aider à prendre
soin de vous et éventuellement à donner
l'alerte vous dites on fait ça ce que
vous avez des tiers qui peuvent évaluer
ça et publier des rapports ou des
évaluations de ça alors ça me permet
monsieur le Président de d'évoquer
quelque chose qui est important c'est
que et on reviendra la dernière question
c'est que effectivement nous avons donc
c'est ces partenariats alors avec la
protection d'enfance de citer et en
France point de contact respecte zone
pour la lutte contre les informations ou
les inspiration au travail avec
génération numérique conspiration
et d'autres donc effectivement on a tout
un panel de ONG d'associations qu'on
associe à nos travaux on a même un
conseil consultatif européen est-ce
qu'il y a des gens qui publient des
rapports ou est-ce que vous envisagez
que des gens publient des rapports
régulièrement pour venir vérifier par
exemple moi si je dis comme mère que mes
jeux dans le parc sont tout à fait
sécurisés évidemment on va me croire sur
ma bonne tête mais c'est mieux quand
j'ai Sécuritas qui qui passe vous voyez
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est cette
logique d'air de tiers de confiance
qu'on utilise aussi pour la sécurisation
des données des centres de données et
effectivement on souhaite le faire aussi
pour pouvoir auditer nos algorithmes de
recommandation nos algorithmes de
modération ou même ce confirmatière
commerciale la librairie de vidéos
commerciales et donc le DSA d'ailleurs
nous oblige à le faire et c'est très
bien puisque on avait déjà qui le fait
voilà donc en fait ce sont des API nous
créons des API en ce moment il y en a
une qui est déjà développée aux
Etats-Unis ces API en fait c'est ce qui
permet à des chercheurs université des
effectivement des experts extérieurs de
pouvoir interroger les algorithmes
pouvoir tester la plateforme est-ce
qu'il y a des tunnels est-ce que on
enferme les gens dans des buses etc vous
avez des rapports de ce type là alors
c'est à dire que nous sommes en train de
déployer ces outils alors oui il y a un
rapport par exemple aux États-Unis parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a commencé aux
États-Unis elle a payé a déjà été créé
et par exemple la Giorgia notek
University donc université de l'État de
Géorgie
a publié un rapport on sera preneur du
rapport voilà on vous l'enverra en fait
c'est un rapport intéressant parce que
c'est un rapport qui établi qu'il n'y a
pas de censure ou de propagande de de la
Chine notamment parce que c'était le
sujet mais même d'autres pays sur sur
Tik Tok donc c'est un rapport important
et cet université est totalement
indépendante et travaille même pour le
Pentagone donc
on vous enverra le rapport bien entendu
sur la dernière question de même
Rossignol et ensuite alors la
déontologie bien entendu à chaque fois
que j'ai
quand j'ai quitté le service public
pour créer ma société puis pour
rejoindre Tik Tok j'ai demandé bien
entendu
de la commission déontologie donc j'ai
deux avis positifs de la commission
d'anthologique d'ailleurs je peux vous
remettre si vous le souhaitez et quand
j'ai rejoint Tik Tok j'ai même demandé
d'ailleurs mon déontologue de
l'Inspection des finances m'a conseillé
de saisir la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique que j'ai
saisie et qui a estimé que j'ai en fait
je n'avais pas à la saisir dans ce cas
de figure voilà mais donc j'ai fait
toutes les démarches pour m'assurer de
cette déontologie que je ne prenais pas
de risque et je faisais pas prendre de
risques à mon administration et la
question de savoir pourquoi j'ai pas
démissionné d'une part parce que la
règle en fait c'est que on se met en
disponibilité et puis au bout d'un
certain temps on est démissionné de fait
voilà donc c'est ce qui applique
l'ensemble de mes collègues à ma
connaissance alors pourquoi pas
démissionner alors c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois que que l'administration m'a
demandé de m'intéresser à un problème
public c'est vrai que j'ai tendance
spontanément à essayer de dire oui parce
que je suis un passionné de la cause
publique
voilà donc je n'ai pas d'autres choses à
dire il me semble que c'est une façon
aussi de servir son pays que de
travailler dans une entreprise
particulièrement innovante
particulièrement disruptive et que ce
savoir que j'accumule peut être utile à
mon pays et je pense d'ailleurs que tous
les salariés de Tik Tok SAS en France
ils sont ils sont très jeunes pour la
plupart ils se disent voilà je travaille
pour une entreprise qui est en France je
travaille aussi pour mon pays et j'aide
des entités des musées des le Pôle
emploi par exemple j'aide les armées à
recruter des jeunes
sur vous OK
merci monsieur le Président il y a bien
d'anciens ou fonctionnaires qui ont
rejoint quantité d'entreprises
extra-européennes du domaine de du
numérique c'est un vaste sujet chers
collègues Charleroi
sans doute un peu plus tard j'ai deux
questions si vous me le permettez
monsieur le Président la première est
dans le prolongement des questions de
Madame Rossignol concernant les
algorithmes qui sont notre grande
préoccupation parce que ces algorithmes
sont conçus pour enfermer pour capter
l'attention et bien sûr
c'est une proclamation notamment il y a
de nos jeunes à des âges critiques ou on
est dans des phases d'apprentissage et
de découverte du monde
vous savez que d'ici quelques semaines
maintenant d'ici trois mois le DSA
s'appliquera
pour ma part ayant été rapportés ce
projet de règlement pour notre
commission des affaires européennes je
pense que nous ne sommes pas allés assez
loin notamment concernant le contrôle et
l'évaluation des des algorithmes
est-ce que dans le cadre de
l'application du DSA et peut-être pour
aller plus loin pour rassurer justement
les utilisateurs la plateforme TikTok
est prête à se laisser auditer par des
chercheurs indépendants tout type
confondus et prête aussi peut-être à
rapprocher ces dates d'évaluation pour
ma part je trouve que c'était trop trop
espacés
est-ce que également vous comptez
recruter un peu plus de monde parce que
la modération la veille c'est le sujet
le plus important en réalité pour être
compatible avec l'exécution de ce
règlement
est-ce que vous opposerez forcément le
secret des affaires justement à ces
outils des des algorithmes qui sont au
cœur de de la problématique voilà une
première série de questions je voulais
vous poser je dis ça aussi parce que il
y a quelques jours
un géant des représentant des big tech
et le must pour pas le citer qui s'est
retiré derrière du code des bonnes
pratiques en ligne laisser entendre que
voilà Twitter n’appliquerait pas
forcément l'application du du dessin il
était en cela d'ailleurs repris par le
commissaire européen terrible breton Tik
Tok clairement s'engageait vraiment
entre pleinement dans l'application du
dessin
avant que vous ne répondiez c'est pour
la bonne organisation des débats dans la
mesure où il y a une partie également
sur les sur les algorithmes bien
évidemment je propose que nous notions
les questions d'amour de saillie pour
faire un paquet global pour pas qu'on se
disperse si vous en êtes d'accord
oui la seule chose c'est que
voilà pouvez-vous répondre alors
succinctement sur la sur la question du
DSA de son application de ce que vous
comptez faire et enfin succinctement non
répondez mais simplement on en reparlera
après sur les doses d'aspects
l'algorithmes parce que je veux dire
bien sûr merci monsieur le Président et
merci Madame merci sénatrice
j'attends la réponse à la première
question si vous voulez
la question est fondamentale donc merci
de la poser bien entendu nous
appliquerons le DSA nous serons au
rendez-vous en août prochain et nous
sommes déjà au rendez-vous en réalité
sur un certain nombre de dispositifs
nous avons eu le plaisir d'accueillir la
com à Dublin à notre centre de
transparence
puisque nous avons deux centres de
transparence nous en avons un aux
États-Unis depuis 2020 et nous avons un
centre de transparence à Dublin et
l'arcom a pu échanger avec des cadres de
très haut niveau de l'entité trust and
safety de l'entité juridique et nous
avons justement voulu avoir cette
échange sur le sur le DSA et donc la
réponse est oui nous voulons être le
plus transparent possible sur les
algorithmes de recommandation de
modération nous développons les API qui
sont demandés par le DSA et nous sommes
très heureux qu'elle puisse être bientôt
ouverte nous avons travaillé avec le
médialab de Sciences Po par exemple en
bêta test sur l'API qui concernait les
bibliothèques de vidéos commerciales et
cette opération s'est très bien passée
de part et d'autre et donc oui nous
sommes aussi avec le vigime sur les les
ingérences sur les risques d'ingérence
nous travaillons avec le pérenne à Bercy
au ministère des Finances et nous sommes
ouverts à travailler avec des
universitaires il faut juste évidemment
que ce soit fait correctement dans des
bonnes conditions de sécurité puisqu'on
sait que parfois c'est aussi des
ouvertures à considérer de qui ont qui
ont aussi suscité des problèmes parce
que après vous allez pouvoir des
personnes malveillantes aussi qui
essaient d'utiliser cette information
donc dès lors que c'est bien fait dans
des conditions de sécurité qui sont
d'ailleurs prévues par le DSA nous
voulons faire un exercice de
transparence maximale en direction des
chercheurs et des autorités de
régulation je ne veux pas anticiper
peut-être une question du rapporteur
mais vous avez parlé des agences
étrangères pouvez-vous ici affirmer que
par exemple la différence d'une
plateforme comme facebook qui dans
l'affaire comment j'ai Activia a
démontré qu'elle a disposé de failles de
backdows pour utiliser un anglicisme
pouvez-vous garantir que Tik Tok ne
dispose d'aucune faille alors ce que ce
que ce que l'on publie régulièrement
maintenant dans y compris dans notre
rapport de transparence ce sont les
tentatives
d'intrusion d'ingérence les
comportements authentiques
inauthentiques coordonnées donc dès que
nous détectons ce genre de choses ça
peut arriver
dans ce cas là évidemment nous
intervenons tout de suite pour retirer
compte et nous publions nous publions
les résultats en France par exemple tout
s'est bien passé lors des dernières
élections donc non seulement on a fait
un très bon travail d'information mais
on n'a pas repéré de tentatives
d'ingérence dans les élections
françaises
au Kenya on a on a remarqué que il y
avait eu ces tentatives et qui ont été
déjoués et donc on veille à chaque fois
d'une part à mettre en place des équipes
de veille renforcer lorsqu'il y a des
élections et d'autre part à communiquer
sur les résultats de cette action de
veille que nous avons et qui est qui est
très forte
sur les données la sécurisation de nos
données vous avez parlé de Data Center
qui était en construction donc en Europe
mais il n'y a pas que la question de
l'hébergement des données il y a la
question de leur traitement et surtout
il y a la question
des lois extraites territoriales qui
font que on est bien démunis face
justement à cette sécurisation
de nos données
vous avez dit que vous disposez des
meilleurs outils technologiques pour
empêcher ces données de nous échapper
comment pouvez-vous l'affirmer parce que
dans dans la réalité on sait bien que
les données sont tout à fait capables
par ces pays étrangers
merci pour pour cette question donc
là nous nous plaçons toujours dans la le
pire des cas où effectivement un
individu essaie de pénétrer le système
donc c'est d'ailleurs toutes les
entreprises essaient de Paris ce risque
donc la façon dont nous avons et on nous
travaillons à éviter ce risque c'est
effectivement de localiser les centres
des données au plus près des des pays
dans lesquels on opère et c'est pour ça
qu'on développe ces trois Data Center à
Dublin et en Norvège ensuite on utilise
à la fois nos protections internes et un
tiers de confiance européen pour aussi
rassurer y compris vous rassurer aussi
sur le fait que on ne repose pas que sur
eux-mêmes comme sur rapporteur monsieur
le Président avec Veritas voilà nous on
travaille aussi avec des tiers de
confiance qui vont effectuer ces tests
et qui vont assurer cette cette
sécurisation ensuite on diminue au
maximum
les besoins de d'accès aux données ou
les transferts de au maxi au minimum
c'est à dire on est une plateforme de
communication internationale on n'est
pas une banque on n'est pas un
coffre-fort donc comme on a une
plateforme de communication il est
normal que les vidéos circulent moi
quand je veux quand vous faites une
vidéo vous voulez qu'elle soit vue par
un maximum de personnes mais si par
exemple j'ai une vidéo que je mets en
mode public et finalement je change
d'avis je veux la remettre en mode privé
il faut bien que l'information puisse
circuler pour que cette vidéo soit
ensuite rebasculée en mode privé donc la
donnée il y a bien une donnée qui va
circuler donc on peut pas on peut pas
dire il y aura pas de circulation de
données de la façon qu'on a des dates
analystes qui doivent pouvoir analyser
aussi quelle est l'efficacité d'un
filtre par exemple une fonctionnalité
mais dans ce cas-là ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va agréger les données on va
les anonymiser on va faire en sorte que
ne soit pas rattaché à des à des comptes
particuliers donc réduction du volume
d'échange de données ou réduction des
nombres d'accès aux données notamment
les données personnelles et après c'est
même réduction du nombre de personnes
qui peuvent avoir accès à ces données
donc on travaille sur ces trois sur ces
trois piliers qui nous permettent selon
nous d'assurer le meilleur niveau de
sécurité possible et peut-être de
contribuer à définir un nouveau standard
de sécurité et finalement une
application de ce principe de
souveraineté numérique qui vous est cher
notamment de souveraineté européenne
je propose que monsieur le rapporteur
puisse justement
mettre les choses en perspective sur les
données
et on reprendra les questions derrière
sur le sujet bien sûr monsieur cardan
monsieur gatelin et j'ai eu madame
bourra aussi
[Musique]
alors en ce qui concerne les transferts
de données jusqu'en juin 2022 TikTok
répétait sans cesse empêcher tout
transfert ou consultation des données
des utilisateurs vers la Chine par la
Chine
jusqu'à ce que BuzzFeed révèle le
contenu de 80 enregistrements audio
issus de réunions internes à
l'entreprise
on s'est aperçu que des ingénieurs de
l'application partage de vidéo ont eu
accès depuis la Chine à pas mal
d'informations
les enregistrements de bus 8 prouvaient
l'existence d'un administrateur
principal je cite en Chine qui avait
accès à tout
je cite encore tout est vu en Chine
affirme un membre du trust saint-safti
département
des enregistrements de huit salariés
américains montrent qu'ils ont dû se
tourner vers leur collecte chinois pour
savoir comment circuler les données de
leurs concitoyens ils n'avaient pas la
permission d'y accéder eux-mêmes
[Musique]
rapporteur la situation est celle que je
viens de décrire c'est à dire que mais
je peux aller un peu plus dans les
détails c'est à dire que à la fois la
construction de du projet Texas aux
États-Unis et la
création des dettes à Center et de
dispositifs de protection qui sont mis
en oeuvre en Europe sont destinés à
éviter toute tout transfert de données
non autorisées tout accès à nos autorisé
avec la certification d'une entité
tierce et d'une entité européenne dans
le cas du projet Clover dans le cas du
projet américain on est allé encore plus
loin parce que c'est même Oracle le
Cloud dorak qui gère et cette
opérationnel qui gère les données des
utilisateurs américains dans une entité
une enclave sécurisée qui s'appelle usds
avec 1000 employés qui travaillent un
investissement d'un milliard 500
millions de dollars aux États-Unis et en
Europe nous sommes en train nous avons
engagé un investissement d'un milliard
200 millions d'euros qui sera une des
points à un investissement annuel pour
assurer cette la mise en oeuvre de de ce
dispositif donc c'est de cette manière
que nous pouvons éviter tout risque
d'intrusion d'accès non autorisé
alors c'est un des problèmes avec Tik
Tok comme d'ailleurs c'est pas
spécifique comme avec toutes les
plateformes c'est-à-dire qu'on prend
toujours des engagements
et qu'on tarde beaucoup beaucoup aller
voir venir le projet Texas ça fait 4 ans
ça fait 2019 qu'il a été annoncé qu'il
est travaillé qu'on annonce Oracle etc
ça fait quatre ans et en 2019 pendant
qu'il a été annoncé Tik Tok avait
quelques années seulement il a pas eu de
problème pour se développer à toute
vitesse
donc jusqu'où ce qui va falloir attendre
que les choses se mettent en place
jusqu'où pendant combien de temps est-ce
qu'on va prendre des engagements sur les
transferts de données sur ceci cela de
la même façon le projet Clover vous avez
annoncé déjà il y a au moins un an ou
deux en Europe vous n'avez pas voulu
révéler jusqu'à présent les le nom des
sociétés avec laquelle vous avec
lesquels vous comptez travailler ce qui
est pas vraiment une preuve de
transparence évidente est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous dire aujourd'hui et
surtout est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner une une date
laquelle le projet Texas sera
définitivement mis en place et une date
à laquelle le projet Clover sera
définitivement mis en place parce que ça
peut encore durer 5 ans avec des
engagements permanents auprès de la
Commission européenne auprès de l'arcom
auprès des régulateurs c'est un vrai
problème le fait que qu'on ne puisse pas
obtenir des plateformes autre chose que
des engagements qui ne sont pas tenus
par ailleurs j'ajoute juste une question
puisque qui reprend ce que vous venez de
dire vous nous avez dit que tout
transfert de données non autorisé sera à
partir de ces projets impossible moi ce
que je souhaiterais ce n'est pas que
tout transfert de données non autorisées
soit impossible c'est que tout transfert
de données soit impossible à ce
moment-là on pourra dire que vous êtes
indépendant de la Chine mais pour le
moment vous nous dites tout transfert de
données non autorisées c'est-à-dire que
vous comptez autoriser des données
encore vers différents pays et notamment
vers la Chine alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire lorsque ce sera terminé
il n'y aura plus de transfert de données
du tout ce jour-là vous pourrez nous
dire on n'a plus rien à avec le PC
chinois le gouvernement chinois et les
sociétés chinoises filiales de baidas
merci monsieur le rapporteur je recevais
hier une photographie de Norvège de ma
collègue qui visitait le chantier de
construction du centre de données de
Norvège et c'était on était tous heureux
de le voir sortir de terre donc en fait
les projets se réalisent il y a des gens
Data Center à Dublin qui est qui est
construit le deuxième sera bientôt
construit donc vous demandez une date
nous avons annoncé la date de 15 mois
voilà le délai de 15 mois peut vous dire
dans 15 mois nous reviendrons vers vous
et normalement le projet Clover le
projet européen sera réalisé c'est
l'engagement que nous avons formulé
devant le ministre en charge du
numérique journal barreau il y a
quelques mois vous construisez le centre
voilà et nos Lego
c'est green par exemple en Norvège green
Lanton et
le nom qui n'est pas communiqué pour
l'instant c'est le nom de du tiers de
confiance tout simplement parce que nous
sommes en négociation comme je disais
c'est un projet un milliard 200 millions
d'euros annuels donc c'est un très gros
projet et donc les discussions
commerciales se déroulent avec les
différentes entreprises et là aussi on
peut en tout cas s'engager à revenir
vers vous dans quelques mois en tout cas
dès que cette négociation sera terminée
voilà ce que je peux dire sur les délais
et sur
et sur le tiers de confiance
quant à l'accès aux données
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
dis toi qui est une plateforme de
communication donc en fait des données
doivent circuler mais quand on parle de
données il s'agit aussi de vidéos c'est
pas toujours des données personnelles
c'est donc quand vous avez acheté une
vidéo qui circule de temps en temps il a
un mode privé en mode public donc voilà
il faut pouvoir aussi que des
métadonnées circulent quand vous sortez
une une fonctionnalité nouvelle il faut
pouvoir analyser sa performance donc ça
aussi c'est les données mais c'est pas
des données personnelles c'est juste de
savoir combien de fois le filtre a été
utilisé donc c'est des données banales
des données produits
et puis parfois il faut corriger des
bugs quand vous avez un compte par
exemple vous avez une vidéo d'un seul
coup le compteur tombe à zéro c'est
qu'il y a un bug ce bug il faut il faut
pouvoir le régler donc ça peut être un
ingénieur qui est à Londres ça peut être
un ingénieur qui est à Singapour
voilà il peut être il peut être
n'importe où le tout c'est que le bug
soit autorisé et qui soit qui soit réglé
pardon et qui soit réglé par la personne
qui est autorisée à intervenir sur le
sur la machine admettons que monsieur le
rapporteur vous ai dit dans sa question
les données personnelles si on doit
reformuler donc sur les données
personnelles autrement que dans les cas
que vous avez décrit
quid parce que vraiment il y a pas de
transfert de données
la notion de données personnelles
est-elle même une notion complexe donc
je préfère revenir par écrit vers vous à
ce sujet si vous me permettez
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
dans le futur est-ce que tout transfert
de données non autorisées sur un
possible ou tout transfert de données
tout court
donc comme je le disais une donnée en
fait ça peut être une information
banale j'allais dire qui porte sur
l'utilisation
d'un filtre d'une fonctionnalité
et donc ce type de données doit pouvoir
circuler d'un lieu à l'autre pour
pouvoir être analysé on est une
plateforme qui opère dans tous les pays
il faut donc
sauf en Chine effectivement et vous
transférez les données en Chine là je
vous parle par exemple d'un filtre
savoir combien de fois un filtre a été
téléchargé voilà ça c'est une c'est une
donnée qui n'est pas une donnée
personnelle mais il se peut qu'il soit
utile de faire circuler cette
information pour pouvoir améliorer le
produit
on a du mal à
comprendre je poursuis ma question vous
nous dit Tic-Toc et lui sont désormais
complètement séparés vos réponses
écrites vous ne dites Tik Tok n'est pas
disponible en Chine continentale tandis
que douillet n'est pas disponible en
dehors de la Chine continentale aucune
donnée personnelle n'est partagée entre
ces deux entités
bon c'est la première chose vous nous
avez répondu c'est une réponse et votre
réponse à nous d'estimer si elle est
satisfaisante je continue pourtant selon
sa politique de confidentialité c'est
sur votre site Tik Tok transmet des
données à des entités en Chine
par ailleurs vous avez déclaré à la CNIL
transférer des données à une vingtaine
d'entreprises chinoises
si ce ne sont pas des entités de
douilline puisque vous nous dites on
travaille pas avec douille est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire que sont ces
entités
vous faites référence à un rapport de
CNIL peut-être que je reviendrai vous
l'avez déclaré en 2020 je pense que le
rapport est public c'est pas il est pas
il est pas confidentiel d'accord c'est
aussi me permettait comme c'est un fait
très précis je préfère à l'analyser et
revenir vers vous de manière écrite sur
ce sujet
je me demande si on voulait le bon là
c'est qu'on vous l'a demandé dans nos
questions écrites et que vous nous avez
pas répondu et qu'aujourd'hui vous ne
répondez pas alors un jour ou l'autre la
commission d'enquête sera terminée
les réponses mais c'est quand même
vous nous confirmer ce que vous avez dit
à la CNIL qu'il y a 20 entités en Chine
avec lesquels vous travaillez je préfère
vous répondre par écrit mais dans un
délai rapide si vous permettez
[Musique]
alors
vous nous dites que Tik Tok travaille
pas du tout en Chine et vous indiquez
dans
sur votre site ou dans les réponses que
nous avons faites je me rappelle plus
que TikTok je cite a été lancé en Europe
en 2018 les équipes produits et
ingénierie situées dans le monde entier
notamment aux États-Unis en Europe à
Singapour et en Chine travaille en
continu à son développement et son
évolution
vous parlez Tik Tok donc est-ce qu'il y
a des employés de Tik Tok en Chine là je
parle pas d'autres entités mais de Tik
Tok puisque vous parlez deux Tik Tok ou
bien ce que ce sont des employés
d'autres sociétés et notamment de
douiller
à ma connaissance je n'ai pas
connaissance d'employés de Tik Tok en
Chine mais c'est Amazon je ne suis donc
je ne suis que chargé des relations
institutionnelles pour la France oui
mais vous rencontrez en permanence des
ministres des régulateurs des
commissaires européens etc je suppose
que toutes les questions qu'on vous
posent elles ont dû largement aux êtres
posés vous êtes directeur des relations
des relations publiques et
institutionnel
je parle c'est vous qui parlez d'équipe
produit et ingénierie
donc il y a des équipes produits
ingénierie
dans une dans des sociétés qui ne sont
pas TikTok puisque vous nous dites en
Chine et on sait pas lesquels c'est pas
très transparent
si vous avez des peut-être des questions
plus précises peut-être sur la
j'ai c'est vous qui êtes imprécis dans
votre réponse je peux pas vous en dire
plus puisque si vous dites je vous
recite je peux pas aller plus loin les
équipes produits ingénierie située dans
le monde entier notamment aux États-Unis
en Europe à Singapour en Chine travaille
en continu à son développement et son
évolution c'est à vous d'être plus
précis moi je vous demande quels sont
ces équipes bon vous me dites
par écrit en tout cas comme je vous
indiquais ce qui est vraiment nous
semble être le plus important c'est de
vérifier que notre nouveau système soit
parfaitement étanche et que les accès
soient autorisés du moins autorisés pour
des raisons très précises
peut-être tu voulais parler de données
alors après moi je voudrais passer aux
algorithmes
on va prendre les questions tout
ensemble et je me suis répondra
aussi avec l'actualité sur notamment la
proposition de loi
sur les influenceurs je voulais quand
même vous écouter sur comment vous allez
parce que vous monsieur malgré vous pose
des questions sur le juridique vous
répondez opérationnel moi je vous pose
des questions sur l'opérationnel pour
vous amener vers le juridique
notamment sur comment vous allez mettre
en place vos équipes pour le contrôle
des promotions interdites et puis sur le
fait de
d'imposer la mention publicitaire
l'identification aussi des influenceurs
que pensez-vous d'ailleurs de de
d'imposer peut-être un badge sur ce que
c'est un influenceur à dimension
commerciale et un influenceur tout court
parce qu'il y a des influenceurs qui se
font à Muret d'autres non en
l'occurrence en tout cas ils font pas la
promotion totalement de produits voilà
je voulais avoir votre avis sur sur
l'actualité à ce niveau là et je
laisserai mes collègues sur le la
protection des données et peut-être vous
poser une question très simple pourquoi
avoir autant dépensé de milliards ou de
millions de dollars sur la stratégie du
lobbying si l'application est totalement
viable serait enfin si vous êtes serein
si vous n'avez pas de si vous avez rien
à
à cacher ou à vous avez envie d'être
transparent de A à Z enfin j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il y a autant
d'argent de mis en place pour faire du
lobbing avec l'application Tik Tok
monsieur gatelin on va
dire merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur je voulais
peut-être rebondir sur deux trois
informations que vous avez dit jusqu'à
présent il y a une chose qui m'a
beaucoup étonné vous avez dit nous
travaillons avec le pérenne avec viginum
on les a auditionnés vous ne travaillez
pas avec eux c'est eux qui vous
demandent de coopérer et de donner des
informations c'est pas une coopération
je dirais de père à père c'est des
instances des autorités qui vous
demandent des informations et moi qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'ils en ont
certaines mais qui n'ont pas tout ce qui
voudrait je tiens à être précis sur plan
sémantique un autre aspect vous avez
évoqué j'ai été
impressionné par le volume
concernant le trust and safety en
Irlande vous parlez de 40000 personnes
alors je suis un peu étonné parce que il
existe et vous l'avez dit un peu plus
tard un choff trust and safety Amérique
qui était dirigé d'ailleurs par herican
qui a quitté ses fonctions suite à des
auditions aux Etats-Unis où il a dit
qu'il voulait pas être un Skype Skype
goat c'est à dire un bouc émissaire
son unité aux États-Unis c'est 1400
personnes donc à 1400 personnes pour
faire de la modération aux États-Unis
qui ont des premiers marchés de TikTok
il y en aurait 40 000 en Europe donc
j'ai du mal à voir comme si vous
permettez de corriger tout de suite
c'est 40000 mondialement
il se trouve que le responsable mondial
de cette entité est en Irlande voilà
c'est ça mais d'accord
parce que c'est un aspect important pour
comprendre aussi l'emploi parce qu'on a
très peu d'éléments sur quels sont en
dehors de Biden proprement dit et
douille qu'elle est aujourd'hui le
volume d'employés quand je vois dans les
sites américains quand on travaille
justement autre chose qui c'est une
rémunération annuelle
il y a deux ans entre 60 et 60 000 65000
dollars par an ça fait quand même
beaucoup d'argent d'avoir une masse
salariale un peu chargée mais on
reviendra je pense plus tard sur la
question des des logiques et des
équilibres économiques alors évidemment
quand on est un groupe il y a des
logiques de mutualisation
j'imagine que on parlait des données des
transferts de données c'est une chose il
y a une mutualisation technologique ça
je peux comprendre qu'il y a des
échanges y compris avec la société mère
il y a une question quand on parle de
trust and
on nous parle en fait de modération des
contenus ce qui est quelque chose de
très important mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quelle protection et
quelle cybersécurité des plateformes
parce que une des choses qui est
importante et on le sait chaque année
dans tous les pays et toutes les
plateformes qu'elles soient elles font
l'objet d'actane et franc l'objet de vol
de donner quel est un le niveau de
cybersécurité de Tik Tok est-ce que vous
avez déjà fait l'objet d'attaque
notamment en France quel est le nombre
de ces attaques et est-ce qu'on vous a
alors je sais que c'est toujours
compliqué en termes d'images déjà voler
des données on nous en vole dans des
grandes bases de données françaises là
il s'agit pas de savoir si vous
transférez volontairement vers
l'étranger vers tel ou tel pays des
données mais quel est votre capacité de
résistance au vol et c'est quelque chose
de massif à corps russe ou autre
extrêmement important et donc est-ce que
vous êtes totalement sécurisé vous
pouvez garantir que vos données ne sont
pas volées ou en tous les cas qui sont
très protégés et surtout est-ce que vous
faites concrètement l'objet d'attaque
comme tous les autres groupes de quelle
manière vous avez évoqué la coopération
avec l'ancien généralement demande aux
grandes entreprises y compris les
entreprises privées aujourd'hui de
déclarer les attaques qui sont faites
est-ce que vous avez procédé à des
signalements et à des déclarations voilà
ce sont mes questions pour l'instant
merci
sur les données justement on va prendre
la question madame pourrait également
puisqu'on est sur le sujet
est-ce que vous allez répondre de
manière groupée très rapidement Tik Tok
est venu infliger en France par la
Commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés donc la CNIL mi-janvier
une amende de 5 millions d'euros car les
utilisateurs ne peuvent y refuser les
cookies les traceurs informatiques la
plateforme a aussi été condamnée au
Royaume-Uni à une amende de plus de 12
millions d'euros début avril pour
l'utilisation illégale de donner liées
aux enfants donc je voudrais savoir si
c'est condamnation conduite TikTok à
opérer des adaptations des évolutions
pour se mettre en conformité puis
j'imagine qu'avant d'arriver à la
condamnation il y a eu des signalements
il y a eu des alertes je voulais savoir
pourquoi est-ce que Tik Tok a vite tardé
si Tik Tok s'est mis en conformité ou à
opérer des changements pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle avait tardé à se mettre en
conformité combien de temps il a eu
entre les premiers les premières alertes
lancées à Tik Tok et
l'amande qui a été infligée je vous
remercie
alors merci monsieur le Président et
merci Madame sénatrice et Monsieur
sénateur donc je vais répondre dans
peut-être dans l'ordre donc sur les sur
les influenceurs donc nous avons
évidemment participé aux travaux qui ont
été conduits au sein du ministre du
ministère des Finances pilotés par le
ministre lui-même d'ailleurs et qui se
sont articulés ensuite avec la
proposition de loi
Vegeta de la porte puisqu'on a eu un
rapprochement de plusieurs propositions
de loi on a salué d'ailleurs le
caractère très constructif et de cette
démarche et le résultat final de la loi
pense et tout à fait intéressant on
avait déjà mis en oeuvre en fait chez
Tik Tok des dispositifs d'une part pour
restreindre la publicité sur certains
produits donc on a notre liste de
produits interdits de publicités et déjà
très importante chez Tik Tok le sujet
par exemple de la de la chirurgie
esthétique avait été mentionné y compris
par le ministre et donc ça fait partie
des sujets sur lesquels on ne peut pas
faire de publicité chez Tik Tok comme
les produits pharmaceutiques le tabac
l'alcool etc et on veille aussi à ce que
les publicités ciblées ne soient pas
dirigé vers des publics mineurs donc ça
c'est aussi quelque un engagement que
nous avons pris avant même le vote de la
loi
nous interdisons aussi les jeux d'argent
les paris sportifs voilà donc tous ces
ensuite sur le sur le signalement des
vidéos faisant l'objet d'une promotion
donc nous avons déjà cette
fonctionnalité qui est qui est demandé
et d'ailleurs même quand un créateur
présente un produit de marque dans une
vidéo
quand l'algorithme détecte cette vidéo
on lui propose spontanément de Sigler sa
vidéo comme s'agissant d'une vidéo
faisant l'objet d'une promotion voilà
donc ça c'est des sujets sur lesquels on
est très attentif et on veillera aussi à
travailler en
bonne int elligence en avec la dgcf qui
qui maintenant a lancé des programmes de
contrôle pour que cette loi soit
pleinement appliquée
alors je n'ai pas bien saisi en fait
quand vous parliez des milliards si
c'était le si ça faisait référence au
projet que j'ai évoquais parce que nous
dépensons pas des milliards en lobbying
mais nous dépensons des milliards en
création de centres de données de ces
questions c'est sur le Bing j'imagine
par rapport au chiffre que vous nous
avez donné dans les questionsnaires sur
votre dépense de d'accord de relation
publique
mais c'est aussi des milliards c'est
pour ça que je comprenais pas et oui
donc non non on est très loin de ces
ordres de grandeur
donc je n'ai pas de commentaires
particuliers à faire si ce n'est que
comme n'importe quelle entreprise nous
avons une direction des relations
institutionnelles et que nous faisons ce
travail d'aller échanger y compris avec
vous ce matin et aussi dans d'autres
commissions nous avons toujours répondu
présent dès lors qu'il y a eu des
demandes d'audition parlementaires sur
tous les sujets donc voilà je pense
qu'on est dans une démarche de
coopération de transparence et que c'est
ça qui fait aussi l'objet de ces de ses
dépenses c'est de préparer au mieux
aussi c'est ces interventions et c'est
et ces discussions
ensuite sur la question de la sécurité
la cybersécurité alors on cherche
justement à établir des relations avec
l'ansy on n'a pas encore eu de
rendez-vous mais on espère avoir un
rendez-vous justement pour se présenter
pour présenter les projets Clover et
pour pouvoir indiquer que on est très
ouvert à ce que l'ancien puisse faire
des tests pour vérifier la robustesse de
nos dispositifs donc voilà on est on est
vraiment très ouvert à cette discussion
et effectivement comme vous le disiez le
nous sommes ce n'est pas un choix mais
nous coopérons comme nous devons le
faire avec vigilum et avec le pérenne et
je pense que ce qui nous manquait
jusqu'ici pour pouvoir répondre à toutes
les questions c'était les API les API
qui permettent d'interroger par exemple
nos algorithmes et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes en train de développer ces API et
que ça permettra aussi de tester
davantage de fonctionnalités ou de
naviguer dans davantage de contenu
voilà donc sur le volume des attaques ce
sont des voilà les des données que je
pense qu'il vaut mieux échanger de
manière confidentielle si vous me
permettez mais on peut échanger tout à
fait sur ces questions là
si je peux la tuer de nombreux comment
dire de nombreuses plateformes ou géant
du web comme on dit en matière de
cybersécurité il y a
comment dire un principe qui est assez
partagé par tout le monde et je pense
que lentilles vous le dira c'est le fait
qu'il faut faire circuler l'information
sur la question des attaques
c'est-à-dire que la même façon que c'est
pas honteuse d'attraper la grippe ou de
d'avoir un accident de la vie de la même
façon quand on est attaqué le plus sûr
c'est de bien partager l'information de
le faire de manière très transversale
entre responsable et d'ailleurs dans le
dans la loi de programmation militaire
il y a des obligations pour les éditeurs
logiciels de faire connaître leurs
failles de la manière la plus rapide
possible je glisse au passage ne
serait-ce qu'en terme de relation
publique oui c'est il y a un caractère
confidentiel mais pour autant vis-à-vis
des personnes des personnes concernées
il faut faire connaître les attaques et
j'espère que vous faites connaître vos
failles de sécurité quand elles ont été
constatées comme tout un chacun aux
responsables
tout à fait d'ailleurs de communiquons
d'ores et déjà je lisais tout à l'heure
sur les les attaques on va dire sur la
plateforme c'est-à-dire des voilà des
tentatives de coordonnées de disséminer
des contenus visant à une des
informations manifeste notamment à
l'occasion de d'élection et là nous
avons communiqué sur ce qui s'est passé
en Allemagne par exemple nous avons
démantelé 3000 comptes qui diffusaient
des fausses informations ou au Kenya
aussi où nous avons pu le faire
découvrir ce type de de réseau donc
voilà de ce point de vue là nous
communiquons
et peut-être un mot sur donc la bande
effectivement de la CNIL donc nous
avions déjà comme poser la question nous
avions effectivement déjà pris la mesure
de cette de cette de cette faille qu'il
fallait corriger
s'agissant des cookies et en fait il
s'agissait de non pas de l'application
Tik Tok qui est évidemment le principal
outil d'accès à Tik Tok c'est
l'application sur les sur les app store
il s'agissait de la web app c'est à dire
de on peut aussi accéder à Tik Tok par
internet et il est vrai que comme c'est
plus mineur en fait les gens vont plutôt
utiliser l'application je pense qu'il y
a eu une négligence sur le fait que les
utilisateurs de Tik Tok par le web
n'était pas forcément informé des
cookies qui pouvaient exister sur la
plateforme donc ça a été corrigé et
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
l'amende de la CNIL alors certes c'est
c'est un montant important mais c'est
vrai que d'autres
d'autres plateformes ont eu des amendes
bien plus importantes parfois plus de 50
millions d'euros donc de ce point de vue
là on pense qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a agi
avec avec rapidité
et bien entendu on est dans un processus
d'amélioration constante dans tous les
domaines y compris ce domaine
l'utilisation des données des enfants en
Angleterre
on est vraiment très vigilant justement
à ce que les publics mineurs soient le
mieux protégé possible qui soit pas
exposé à certaines publicités ou
et que les contenus qu'ils voient aussi
soient des contenus les plus adaptés à
leur âge
sur un porteur
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
poser revenir au problème de
l'algorithme ou des algorithmes
nous avions posé la question
qui détient la propriété intellectuelle
due au désalgorithmes au niveau mondial
vous n'avez pas répondu
nous vous avons posé la question y
a-t-il un algorithme ou des portions
d'algorithme commun entre Tik Tok et
douille vous avez répondu de façon
particulièrement brève il n'y a pas
d'algorithme commun ni de partie
d'algorithmes communs entre TikTok et
douillet
en outre la Chine par la voie de son
secrétaire d'État au Commerce a
récemment affirmé que la Chine refusait
la vente de TikTok au motif qu'elle ne
voulait pas perdre ses technologies
elle a ajouté les technologies
algorithmiques utilisées par Tic-Toc et
par douilline à la liste des
technologies inexportables sans
l'autorisation du gouvernement chinois
bloquant et
une éventuelle vente de Tik Tok a des
étrangers
comment expliquer cette déclaration si
Tik Tok et douillet sont totalement
séparés et si Tik Tok est totalement
indépendant du gouvernement chinois
donc monsieur le rapporteur les les
algorithmes sont en effet différenciés
entre des deux des deux applications et
donc ce sont des équipes spécifiques qui
développent l'algorithme de
recommandations de Tik Tok
et comme indiqué le la chaîne
capitalistique et juridique qui descend
de bindens à Tik Tok
doit permettre de de faire en sorte
qu'il n'est pas de pression qui soit
exercée à l'encontre de la plateforme à
Tik Tok ensuite je pense que ce qui est
important par rapport à vos
préoccupations légitimes c'est que des
algorithmes soient
auditables qu'on puisse vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas de biais algorithmique ni dans
le sens de la censure de la propagande
ou de la désinformation
et de ce point de vue là nous
développons de ces API qui vont
permettre aux autorités de régulation
aux chercheurs la communauté
scientifique d'interroger ses
algorithmes et de vérifier qu'il n'y a
pas de des billets qui soit contraire à
l'intérêt général j'allais dire
alors je vous repose la question qui
détient la propriété intellectuelle due
aux dés algorithmes au niveau mondial
par écrit sur cette question en tout cas
il semble logique que ce soit que ce
soit Biden ce qui soit propriétaire de
ces de ces algorithmes
ça n'a pas l'air d'être la vie du
gouvernement chinois puisque le
gouvernement chinois dit les
technologies algorithmiques utilisées
par Tik Tok et du Yin sont des
technologies chinoises des des
propriétés intellectuelles chinoises et
elles sont inexportables sans
l'autorisation du gouvernement chinois
donc il semble bien en tout cas la vie
du gouvernement chinois c'est que la
propriété intellectuelle elle appartient
à une société chinoise
ce n'est pas de commentaires à faire sur
sur des déclarations de quelques
gouvernements que ce soit monsieur le
rapporteur
mais vous vous pensez que si vous voulez
vendre si un jour pas seulement sous les
injonctions du gouvernement américain
mais ceci un jour
soucis de chou et ses associés voulaient
vendre Tik Tok
vous constatez qu'apparemment ça
poseront des problèmes avec le
gouvernement chinois et que par
conséquent es vous pouvez pas
prononcer sur le gouvernement chinois
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle Tik Tok et coincé
s'il veut
opérer des opérations et notamment des
opérations qui ont appliquerait
l'utilisation de son algorithme
ce que je peux dire c'est que Tik Tok et
le groupe Island c'est dans une logique
de développement de poursuivre sur sa
lancée de continuer à développer voilà
nouveau produit une nouvelle
fonctionnalités et que tout est mis en
mesure tout est fait de telle sorte que
ces algorithmes puissent être auditables
et que s'il y a des préoccupations
légitimes que ces algorithmes puissent
être biaisés manipulés que on puisse
apporter toute réponse de nature à vous
rassurer sur ce point
ou sur d'autres sujets comme on parlait
aussi de du temps de
du côté enfermement des bulles
algorithmiques qu'on puisse aussi vous
apporter des réponses sur ce point
c'est-à-dire voilà tout ce qui peut
concerner des effets néfastes de ces
algorithmes qu'on puisse apporter des
clarifications qui souhaitent nature à
vous rassurer sur le fait qu'ils sont
utilisés non pas pour développer de
l'addiction ou de la toxicité mais au
contraire pour permettre à nos
utilisateurs de s'épanouir
de se divertir de s'instruire et de
communiquer les uns avec les autres dans
un plein soucis de liberté d'expression
moi je vous parle propriété et notamment
la propriété intellectuelle
l'utilisation qui vous faites juste une
remarque au passage les régulateurs et
plusieurs de nos interlocuteurs nous ont
dit que les API de Tik Tok aujourd'hui
étaient embryonnaire par rapport aux
autres sociétés par rapport aux autres
plateformes et que les autres
plateformes sont pas totalement
transparentes mais qu'elles ont des API
qui permettent pas mal pas mal d'accès
ok vous nous mettez des Alpi qui
permettront de vérifier les utilisations
mais moi je vous parle de propriété
aujourd'hui le gouvernement chinois dit
alors est-ce que ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui quelle est la part de de
l'algorithme quelle est la part des de
l'ingénierie sur l'algorithme qui est
effectué en Chine ou qui est effectué
ailleurs mais apparemment une bonne
partie l'algorithme chinois au départ
l'algor
au départ il est séparé mais il semble
être majoritairement
utilisé par des ingénieurs d'une société
je sais pas laquelle chinoise
vous devez quand même savoir avec quelle
société chinoise vous travaillez puisque
vous travaillez avec des Chinoises vous
l'avez dit vous-même Tik Tok l'a dit à
la CNIL elle l'a reconnu dans des
auditions vous devez quand même en tant
que directeur des affaires
institutionnels et des affaires
publiques savoir avec quelle société
chinoise TikTok travail s'agissant de
l'algorithme que vous évoquiez
l'algorithme de recommandation je sais
qu'il y a des équipes d'ingénieurs
au Royaume-Uni il y en a aux États-Unis
il y en a Singapour
voilà donc c'est ce que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui et par ailleurs je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
entreprises de technologie beaucoup
d'entreprises occidentales qui ont aussi
des ingénieurs en Chine et je ne crois
pas que ça pose de difficultés la
question en revanche que vous
préoccupation que vous exprimez sur
l'intégrité des systèmes ça bien entendu
nous l'adressons et nous l'adressons par
de dispositifs de sécurisation de des
données des Européens et par
l'auditabilité des algorithmes vous
dites que les API sont embryonnaires
c'est vrai nous sommes en train de les
créer nous sommes une société qui
n'existait pas il y a 6 ans et donc nous
sommes en train de développer ces API et
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
responsable de l'entité 1300 safevety et
le premier à dire il faut que nous
soyons le plus ouvert possible et que
nos systèmes puissent être au
alors à la question 8 que nous avions
posées portant sur les éventuels
systèmes d'information commun entre Tik
Tok et douille vous faites une réponse
imprécise vous répondez sur les données
des utilisateurs et puis vous indiquer
que Tik Tok utilise sa propre plateforme
de collaboration professionnelle qui
s'appelle la
elle a RK utilisé par tous les employés
de baidens vous utilisez donc un
logiciel de messagerie spécifique
le New York Times a indiqué le 24 mai
dernier c'est récent que les messages
des employés de Tik Tok sur la
messagerie d'entreprise l'arc était
largement accessible à des employés en
Chine notre question reformuler et donc
est-ce que l'arc est utilisé en Chine
par les employés de douille quels sont
les messages des employés de Tik Tok qui
sont accessibles aux employés de Douilly
pourquoi les employés de tikloques et
douillets n'utilisent la même messagerie
semble-t-il sans droit d'accès
particulier
si Tik Tok est douillet n'ont rien en
commun
alors si vous permettez Monsieur
rapporteur en fait l'arc c'est une c'est
une application que vous pouvez
télécharger vous-même c'est une c'est
une c'est une messagerie comme il en
existe un grand nombre c'est un peu
comme teams zoom ou
slack aussi voilà donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez c'est un banal outils
d'échange
donc voilà je ne vois pas de
particularité propre à l'arc par rapport
à d'autres outils bureautiques non mais
ce qui me pose problème c'est pas
l'outil c'est le fait que les employés
de Tik Tok et d'urine partagent
allègrement la plateforme
la messagerie l'arc
s'il y a pas aucun rapport entre Tik Tok
et du Yin c'est quand même un peu
surprenant
écoutez en tout cas moi j'utilise mes
collègues j'utilise l'arc pour échanger
au sein de tik tokes SAS vous pouvez
changer avec nos collègues de Tik Tok en
Europe mais voilà nous n'avons pas
d'autres
usages
que je ne sais pas si votre réponse est
non exhaustive ou s'il y a trois petits
points pour échanger avec des collègues
de Tik Tok SS de Tik Tok Europe
en Chine
mais comme comme les deux les entités
sont très séparées nous nos échanges
c'est au sein de Tik Tok donc c'est
voilà on peut échanger aussi avec
l'Amérique latine avec avec les
États-Unis bien entendu avec qui nous
avons des réunions mais c'est
vraiment les réunions se font au sein de
l'entité TikTok là dans votre téléphone
sur vos sur votre application là que je
ne connaissais pas vous n'avez pas de
discussion ouverte avec des des
collègues de bac dance en Chine
pas de douillet en tout cas pas à ma
connaissance d'accord c'est vous qui
savez c'est dans votre poche donc la
réponse est non la réponse est non après
parfois on peut échanger avec quelqu'un
on sait pas exactement d'où il ressort
enfin quel est son entité juridique
que vous échangez avec quelqu'un sans
savoir qu'en ce moment il est pendant
deux mois à Shanghai j'en suis pas à ce
niveau de de comment dire de suspicion
mais vous n'échangez pas avec des
responsables d'identifier chinois sur
l'arc je ne pense pas on a pu échanger
avec des des collègues de Picot puisque
Pico est dans le groupe aussi c'est un
qui crée des casques de réalité
virtuelle mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
Douline c'est c'est une autre entité
d'accord
les centres de données dont vous venez
de nous parler
est-ce qu'ils utiliseront les mêmes
logiciels américains qu'actuellement et
qui sont immatriculés aux États-Unis à
savoir Google cloud Amazon Web Services
et Microsoft et jeux
c'est une question qui a nos yeux est
importante puisqu'elle permet de
déterminer la soumission éventuelle au
Cloud Act américain
alors Monsieur rapporteur l'idée c'est
précisément d'avoir un système différent
entre les États-Unis et l'Europe et que
en Europe on puisse travailler dans la
mesure du possible avec des entreprises
européennes
je peux pas divulguer d'autres d'autres
noms de marques dans une enceinte
publique mais je propose de revenir vers
vous par écrit dans la mesure où on peut
transmettre des informations plus
précises sur ce point
merci alors je vous repose pour la
deuxième fois la question
à laquelle je ne crois pas que vous ayez
répondu qui détient la propriété
intellectuelle due au désalgorithmes de
Tik Tok au niveau mondial
sur cette question je préfère également
si vous me permettez de revenir par vers
vous par écrit
ce que je peux faire ici à mon niveau
c'est vous apporter des précisions sur
la manière dont ces algorithmes sont
utilisés de la manière dont fonctionne
notre dispositif de modération la
manière dont nous pouvons par des API
audités ces algorithmes mais sur la
question de la propriété intellectuelle
elle-même c'est une question trop
technique pour vous répondre ici
juste pour préciser compléter la
question puisque le Royaume-Uni joue un
rôle important dans votre installation
depuis le brexit et la sortie même s'il
y a des accords de prolongation du
système de la propriété intellectuelle
qui était posée par l'Union européenne
on note un dépôt extrêmement massif de
nouveaux patins de nouvelles licences au
Royaume-Uni donc est-ce que vous avez
protégé déposer pour le niveau européen
ou en tous les cas dans le cadre de
votre entreprise
les si vous pouvez nous renseigner sur
les démarches qui sont en termes de
protection justement de la
de la propriété intellectuelle qu'est-ce
qui est fait au Royaume-Uni parce que
c'est une question qu'on se pose puisque
logiquement le Royaume-Uni continue à
poursuivre les règles qui avaient été
posées par l'Union européenne et
parallèlement on voit double système se
mettre en place et le Royaume-Uni tel
fonctionne actuellement à des failles
dans les accords qu'ils ont mis en place
avec l'Union européenne donc ça
m'intéresserait de savoir si Tik Tok ou
les compagnies qui sont liées ont
procédé à ces dépôts tout à fait légaux
puisque ça appartient aux droits
britanniques mais au droit britannique
uniquement
merci Monsieur voilà je
reviendrai vers vous avec moi avec plus
d'informations sur sur ce point ce que
je peux dire en tout cas c'est que Tik
Tok se développe beaucoup en Europe
continentale nous ouvrons des bureaux
régulièrement dans un plus grand nombre
de pays on a commencé avec l'Allemagne
la France
Bruxelles et maintenant nous ouvrons des
bureaux dans d'autres pays de l'Europe
continentale en Europe du Sud notamment
[Musique]
en réponse à la question 35 du deuxième
questionnaire envoyé vous indiquez que
l'expression amélioration de
l'expérience utilisateur ne figure pas
dans votre politique de confidentialité
elle y est pourtant bien présente
puisque vous utilisez le terme optimisé
l'expérience utilisateur comme intérêt
légitime pour partager à des tiers des
informations sur les utilisateurs c'est
une expression qui reste très vague
qu'est-ce qu'elle recouvre concrètement
est-ce que l'utilisateur a selon vous
conscience qu'il partage ses
informations dans ce but très général
alors à ma connaissance on partage pas
de données avec des tiers
sauf dans le cadre des API que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place en
conformité avec le DSA
je pense que vous l'utilisez cette
phrase dans les échanges de données dans
la politique de confidentialité dans les
échanges de données avec des sociétés
étrangères
sans préciser évidemment
il y a des sociétés aux États-Unis à
Malaisie à Singapour en Chine avec
laquelle nous travaillons et parmi les
sujets travaillés optimiser l'expérience
utilisateur
je propose là aussi de revenir par écrit
c'est un point très technique ça vous
permettez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est la procédure sur l'enquête
réglementaire initiée par la difficile
irlandaise
portant sur la conformité de Tik Tok
Airlande avec le rgpd dans le cadre du
traitement des données personnelles
d'utilisateur à jus de moins de 18 ans
entre le 29 juillet 2020 et le 31
décembre 2020
ça fait deux ans que la même plus de
deux ans que la procédure dure je pense
qu'elle touche à sa fin j'ai entendu
dire que la DPC Prométhée ou en tout cas
envisager une réponse une définitive
pour l'été mais avant la réponse
définitive il y a des transferts entre
il y a des échanges entre
j'imagine la difficile et votre société
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où on
en est
alors je n'ai pas d'informations à
partager à cet égard sur le rapporteur
mais
seule chose que je puisse faire c'est
direct
difficile oui on bien sûr je pense que
ce sera ce sera connu
Tik Tok pousse les contenus et notamment
j'utilise ce terme parce que il circule
poussent les conduits et notamment de la
chaîne du festival du livre pour l'aider
à gagner en visibilité c'est un article
dans
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de mots
comment procède-t-on au poussette
combien y a-t-il de pousseur si c'est
des je pense que c'est des interventions
humaines en France et quelle est leur
marge de manœuvre et à qui est-ce qu'ils
auraient faire
merci Monsieur rapporteur je pense que
ma collègue Marlène mesure que oui
en détail moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la proportion des vidéos qui
font l'objet d'une mise en avant
éditoriale et très faible on a fait un
test sur les quelques mois et on était à
0,06 %. donc c'est vraiment marginal
mais c'est évidemment des contenus que
vous étiez le livre c'est plutôt des
contenus justement qu'on met en avant
pour des raisons éducatives culturelles
on est on a très à coeur évidemment de
jouer notre rôle citoyen et de pouvoir
mettre en avant des produits qui
intéressent et des contenus qui
intéressent le plus nos communautés
donc le livre c'est vrai que c'est une
très belle histoire puisque le
mot dièse booktok
est à plus de 150 milliards de vues et
dans le monde et c'est une c'est un
phénomène au départ très organique c'est
à dire c'est une
américaine qui a commencé à faire une
chronique littéraire sur sur Tik Tok
d'un livre qui partait sur Achille donc
un petit était grecque et c'est devenu
une vidéo virale et depuis lors on a
beaucoup de d'utilisateurs de tous les
âges qui font des chroniques littéraires
sur Tik Tok et c'est vrai que nous avons
encouragé ce mouvement en France d'une
part parce que la lecture de livre sont
une cause nationale décrétée comme tel
par la France et nous avions aussi
rencontré le ministre de l'éducation
nationale à l'époque Jean-Michel
Blanquer qui qui souhaitait que voilà
les jeunes qui vont vers les écrans
puissent aussi revenir vers le livre et
la lecture et donc voilà ça ça fait
partie effectivement des choses que nous
avons encouragées on a même mis en place
une interface apprendre sur Tik Tok qui
a déjà 200 millions de vues alors qu'on
vient à peine de la Lancer et qui permet
de se cultiver sur Tik Tok donc ça ça
fait partie des des contenus qui sont
mis en avant parfois par le fait de
créer cette page avec des onglets langue
étrangère histoire
culture et c'est on pense que ça
correspond aussi à un appétit très fort
de curiosité très forte de nos
utilisateurs si vous permettez pour vous
permettre de répondre plus précisément
la question de Monsieur rapporteur je
vais faire le candide
cette responsable des affaires publiques
donc je pense que là pour le coup c'est
vraiment vous qui êtes à la manœuvre ce
serait normal quand vous êtes
j'en sais rien moi une entreprise locale
ou une collectivité vous avez la presse
locale qui tend à autre vient vous
démarcher en disant tiens pour votre
festival de de festival annuel je ne
sais quoi au votre salon on peut faire
un partenariat c'est à dire que il y
aura des reportages sur lesquels vous
n'avez pas la main bien évidemment d'un
point de vue rédactionnel mais on
s'engage à faire pendant une semaine un
reportage dans la page départementale ou
régional sur le salon voilà pour amener
de la visibilité ça existe depuis que le
monde est monde
j'imagine dans le cas d'espèce que à un
moment vous allez voir le Salon du livre
ou le salon du livre vient vers vous et
vous dit et là je voudrais que vous me
répondiez concrètement là c'est pas
combien d'articles j'ai par jour si vous
disent le partenariat c'est que
nous on s'engage à promouvoir
l'application à l'intérieur du Salon du
livre ou l'usage ou le mot dièse booktop
ou que sais-je mais en échange de quoi
vous vous allez pousser le contenu sur
le salon du livre donc ma question est
simple quel est l'objet du marché
c'est-à-dire que vous vous leur dites il
y a bien un moment le journal qui vient
vous voir il vous dit vous aurez un
article par jour vous vous dites quoi
vous serez poussé à hauteur de tant de
vidéos ou l'algorithme sera je veux pas
dire forcée mais l'algorithme sera amené
à mettre du contenu sur le salon du
livre dans sur tant de fils là je pense
que vous pouvez répondre concrètement
sur ces sujets là c'est ça relève
vraiment de la direction contenue et
opération donc je pense que Marlène
mesure vous répondra alors vous avez
quelqu'un de la direction de contenu
opération qui vient avec vous quand vous
rencontrez les personnes d'un salon ou
d'un festival il faut bien que vous
puissiez leur répondre concrètement
parce que que de manière aimable autour
d'un café vous puissiez vous dire que
tout le monde adore la littérature le
cinéma les formats courts et le
surréalisme nouvelle version j'entends
c'est très aimable on est tous friand de
tout ça mais il y a un moment où la
personne elle doit rendre compte elle
aussi à son conseil d'administration il
faut qu'il puisse dire à un moment le
partenariat avec Tik Tok nous a permis
de par exemple le Salon du livre ils ont
dit ça nous a permis d'accroître la
visibilité de tant de pour cent vous
avez même des chaînes d'information j'ai
été très étonné que des rédactions
encore que ces derniers temps on a
appris que les bandeaux parfois c'était
assez aléatoire sur qui décidé du
contenu mais on a eu des bandeaux sur
une chaîne d'information en continu qui
disait littéralement cette année le
Salon du livre a eu tant de visiteurs en
plus grâce à un partenariat TikTok
ça c'est de la bonne c'est de la belle
ouvrage comme on aurait dit ma
grand-mère c'est assez efficace à la fin
c'est ce qui est marqué sur les bandeaux
de chaîne d'information quand vous
démarchez ces gens-là ou quand ils
viennent vous voir mais tout ça n'a rien
de sale c'est comme je vous l'exposé ça
existe dans la presse locale il y a bien
un moment où au-delà du fait de se dire
c'est formidable on va ouvrir pour la
culture tout ça ensemble il y a bien un
moment où quelqu'un leur dit et je pense
que c'est fait partie de votre boulot ou
d'avoir ces personnes avec vous si on a
le partenariat vous serez poussé de
telle façon vous serez vu par tant de
personnes en plus que vous vous ne
sachiez pas ouvrir le capot de
l'ordinateur ou de l'algorithme et faire
tout ça je ça je l'entends bien c'est
parce qu'on vous demande mais quels sont
les quel est l'objet du marché
sur le Festival du Livre de Paris on
peut prendre cet exemple je pense
d'ailleurs qu'on a dû vous transmettre
le contrat de partenariat les choses
étaient assez simples c'est le festival
du livre qui nous a proposé c'est
effectivement ce partenariat c'est son
but c'était effectivement d'accroître sa
communication en direction des jeunes
publiques et effectivement ça a été
plutôt suivi des faits puisque en tout
cas il a été constaté que quasiment 45%
je crois de la fréquentation du total du
service a été des jeunes de moins de 25
ans mais entre les deux c'est parce que
vous vous avez bien travaillé donc c'est
quoi bien travailler vous pousser
combien de contenu sur combien de fils
comment ça marche donc le contenu de ce
partenariat en tout cas c'était d'avoir
un espace au sein de de du festival du
livre pour pouvoir accueillir des
créateurs et favoriser la rencontre avec
des auteurs et pouvoir faire des vidéos
qui ensuite étaient projetées sur Tik
Tok mais Marion je pense on pourra
rentrer davantage dans le détail mais
généralement
je ne pense pas qu'on rentre dans ce
degré de de détails c'est simplement que
le hashtag le mot dièse booktok est un
mot dièse qui est très populaire en soi
et qui peut faire l'objet d'une
éditorialisation particulière sous forme
d'une page dédiée
à la littérature et qui va de temps en
temps mettre en avant des des créateurs
des contenus voilà mais
l'essentiel c'est ça la beauté de la
chose c'est que c'est le phénomène est
très organique ce sont vraiment c'est un
écosystème où certains types de contenus
sont très demandés et donc ça crée de
l'envie pour d'autres créateurs de se
lancer aussi dans ce type de quoi
contenu
non c'était juste pour prolonger la
question donc ça veut dire qu'il y a une
extrême réactivité c'est dans le cadre
du partenariat vous faites vous faites
venir des créateurs Tik Tok in situ et
que ça provoque un afflux ça veut dire
que les gens sont dans une réactivité
quasi immédiate c'est pas quelque chose
qui est monté en amont sur la plateforme
TikTok c'est la production de contenu
qui suscite une réactivité très forte
c'est ça et donc dans ce cadre là est-ce
que vous utilisez par exemple dans le
cadre de l'algorithme de la
géolocalisation parce que excusez moi si
vous habitez à 500 km de de Paris le
Salon du livre vous allez pas vous
déplacer parce qu'il y a un créateur qui
a fait la promotion et venir donc
visiter le dit salon
après alors c'est vrai qu'entre
quel est le déterminant et quel est le
reflet puisqu'on est aussi le reflet de
la société une plateforme et refait la
société moi je pense qu'il y a un
mouvement peut-être plus ancien déjà de
que les de retour à la lecture et au
livre de la part des jeunes il y a
d'autres effets il y a ce que vous
proposez est-ce que vous proposez aux
gens du Salon du livre quand vous dites
le partenariat consiste également à ce
qu'on pousse les contenus de manière
géolocalisée sur les gens susceptibles
de se dire tiens demain on va sûrement
du livre ça n'a rien de sale vous savez
que la presse locale il vous propose
d'écrit de d'envoyer
d'envoyer un truc particulier à tout
leur nouveau abonnés dans votre
département de l'année on vous demande
simplement est-ce que vous est-ce que
par exemple vous êtes en mesure
commercialement peut-être que Madame
nous répondra cet après midi de dire et
bien vous aurez l'assurance que sur
telle zone géographique on poussera le
Salon du livre à tel moment du fait de
la géologue la géolocalisation des
abonnés oui ou non moi ce que je sais
mon niveau c'est que la géolocalisation
est très peu développée ée sur
l'application mais je préfère que
effectivement que ce soit marine masure
qui vous réponde sur ce point-là
Tik Tok devait remettre en janvier à la
commissaire européenne verra janova un
rapport sur la désinformation sur sa
plateforme est-ce que le rapport a été
remis et est-ce que Madame janova a
donné une opinion sur ce rapport merci
Monsieur rapporteur effectivement nous
avons adhéré de manière volontaire au
code européen de lutte contre des
informations et nous avons remis notre
premier rapport à la Commission
européenne nous avons dans ce rapport
divulgué de 2500 données de 1500
informations qui est le rapport a été
remis de manière satisfaisante voilà il
y a eu un accueil satisfaisant c'est ce
que la seule chose que je puisse dire à
ce stade mais nous avons rempli notre
obligation et nous continuerons à la
remplir
je reviens sur la question précédente
parce que j'avais noté quelque chose que
j'ai oublié de vous dire vous nous dites
150 milliards de vues sur les vidéos
booktok sur les documents booktok 150
milliards sur combien de milliards dans
le monde
annuellement alors c'est 145 je prends
le chiffre précis voilà 145 milliards au
jour d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est ce qui est pratique j'allais
dire c'est que ces mots dièse en fait
vous pouvez les suivre en temps réel
puisque il suffit de taper le mot dièse
dans la barre de recherche et vous avez
en temps réel la popularité de tel ou
telle modies donc c'est un ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un mouvement
comme je disais spontané c'est une
utilisatrice qui a créé ce mot dièse et
ensuite c'est devenu viral et maintenant
ça peut faire l'objet effectivement de
d'une plus grande éditorialisation
si vous avez le chiffre le nombre sur
booktok vous avez sans doute le nombre
global mondial
de vue
de l'ensemble des
documents de Tik Tok
dans le monde
alors
en fait ce que cette mesure ça veut dire
qu'il y a 145 milliards de vision de
vidéos qui portent ce modèle en fait et
ça ce que ça veut dire donc comme
booktok ce sont des chroniques
littéraires on peut dire voilà il y a eu
des chroniques littéraires qui ont
circulé sur l'application et qui au
total ont été vu 145 milliards de fois
ça peut être parfois évidemment un
utilisateur qui va regarder deux fois la
même vidéo ça c'est possible aussi mais
c'est disons une une
donnée intéressante sur la popularité la
popularité d'une tendance oui et ce sont
les données publiques que vous pouvez
suivre pour le pour
témoigner de la popularité il faut le
comparer à l'ensemble oui ma question
est simple combien de vues combien de
vidéos combien de milliards de vidéos
toutes catégorie confondues sont vus par
an sur Tik Tok
oui alors je ne sais pas si cette donnée
est disponible quelque part c'est pas
comme si c'est 300 milliards quoi oui
oui
je suppose que c'est pas le cas ce qu'il
faudrait pour connaître la popularité
c'est combien par rapport à l'ensemble
des vues sur l'ensemble des vidéos vues
sur Tik Tok
tout à fait non non vous avez vous avez
raison c'est c'est l'intérêt d'ailleurs
d'avoir ces API de pouvoir aussi faire
ces travaux de quantification
en tout cas pour nous par rapport à aux
ordres de grandeur que que nous avons en
tête c'est le signe d'une grande
popularité
on peut faire l'exercice vous pouvez
vous-même faire l'exercice sur certains
modèles et on voit à quel point c'est
important là par exemple la compétition
de films qui a été faite
récemment Tik Tok short film on peut
voir qu'il y a plus de 9 milliards de
vues donc c'est c'est quelque chose
aussi de tout à fait intéressant puisque
ça n'existait pas il y a deux ans
est-ce que Tik Tok France ça quitte de
sa contribution au CNC
alors en avril 2023 donc c'est tout
récent nous avons fait notre première
déclaration au titre de la taxe sur les
services numériques
donc de ce point de vue là
nous sommes bien en règle de nos
obligations fiscales
la taxe qui est le produit est versé au
CNC fait l'objet d'une discussion entre
les équipes fiscales qui sont donc
regroupés à Tik Tok UK et avec
l'administration fiscale française il y
a des questions qui ont été posées sur
l'assiette de la taxe par nos équipes et
donc Tik Tok est en attente de la
réponse de l'administration fiscale pour
évidemment respecter pleinement ces
obligations quand est-ce que Tik Tok
France a été créé exactement
donc c'était en 2020
donc depuis trois ans pour le moment
vous payez pas encore la contribution au
CNC
vous attendez de voir on attend le on
attend la réponse surtout de
l'administration fiscale qui à ma
connaissance n'a pas encore été donnée
en juillet 2022 Tik Tok a publié un
communiqué expliquant que la société
suspendait la mise à jour de sa
politique de confidentialité qui lui
permettait de se passer du consentement
de ses utilisateurs européens pour les
exposer à la publicité ciblée
cette décision qui intervenait à la
veille de l'entrée en vigueur des
changements faisaient suite à des
discussions ouvertes avec l'autorité
irlandaise de protection des données la
DPC
l'ONG access now qui défend les droits
des internautes avait accusé Tik Tok de
violation manifeste du rgpde européen et
des fins de publicité ciblées depuis
juillet dernier ou un êtes-vous de la
discussion avec la difficile et où on
est de vous du changement de politique
de confidentialité
on est effectivement c'est ces
discussions se poursuivent et
comprendrait qu'il est difficile
d'entrer dans le détail de ces
discussions
il y a beaucoup de discussions qui se
poursuivent longtemps avant d'arriver le
SACD d'ailleurs est assez on en parlera
à Madame masure cet après-midi mais les
sociétés d'auteur et tout sont assez
commencés à être assez je dirais une
litote irritée du fait que ça fait
maintenant des années que ça dure et
qu'il y a pas de conclusion c'est voilà
je vous fais cette remarque oui non mais
on est en discussion effectivement avec
les sociétés de gestion de droit Tik Tok
est une entreprise qui n'existait pas il
y a 6 ans qui en tant pleinement
respecté le droit d'auteur qui respecte
d'ailleurs le droit d'auteur
je vous ai demandé tout à l'heure ce que
on était le traitement par la difficile
de l'enquête sur les transferts de
données vers la Chine il y a une autre
enquête qui est sur le traitement des
données personnelles des enfants est-ce
que vous avez des nouvelles
c'est également un dossier qui suit son
cours je peux pas en dire davantage je
m'excuserez
on a parlé tout à l'heure de la
modération et l'algorithme
en ce qui concerne les modérateurs
humains comment dans la pratique se
répartit la modération entre les
modérateurs français anglophones
britannique ou anglophone chinois ou
autre
alors nous
pouvons vous divulguer parce que c'est
une information qui n'a pas encore été
rendu public que nous avons 600
modérateurs en langue française qui se
fait que dans les chocolats
et donc sur et au total nous avons donc
une force très sainte de 40000 personnes
qui agissent dans toutes les langues
dans ce plus de 70 langues et donc le
travail qui est
l'essentiel du travail fait pardon des
algorithmes des donc l'intelligence
artificielle et les modérateurs
interviennent dans un deuxième temps
pour pouvoir démêler des situations plus
complexes certaines infractions à nos
règles communautaires sont assez faciles
à détecter la pornographie la nudité
l'extrémisme et dès lors qu'il a des
signes utilisent des symboles manifestes
et ensuite vous avez des
des infractions qui sont plus difficiles
à détecter
et qui nécessite un travail de
modération humaine donc c'est c'est à ce
moment là que c'est modérateur
interviennent
et la répartition entre la France les
quand vous dites 600 600 modérateurs
francophones
non ils sont pas non non ils sont basés
dans plusieurs endroits certains sont à
Dublin d'autres dans d'autres centres
comme on est une entreprise
technologique une plateforme
technologique évidemment la question
c'est qu'il soit connecté et encadré qui
puissent aussi avoir des programmes de
formation et qu'on puisse aussi veiller
à leur bien-être parce que c'est un
travail difficile
oui c'est précisément une question que
je voulais poser il y a un complément
donc vous avez une approche linguistique
fondée d'abord sur des algorithmes donc
sur des langages des écritures donc ça
veut dire que l'intervention par exemple
en matière francophone se perd sur toute
conversation qui se fait en français
même si par exemple c'est aux États-Unis
je possède question parce que imaginons
un pays
où une langue utilisée par des gens qui
ont une action terroriste ou dangereuse
ces gens là peuvent opérer en France
dans leur langue donc là vous avez
éventuellement aussi le contrôle qui
s'applique même si c'est pas la langue
française je comprends bien c'est
agnostique comme approche oui bien
entendu c'est si on détecte que c'est
une autre langue ce sera visionné par le
modérateur qui intervient dans la langue
en question ces algorithmes qui
déterminent la langue et qui va
déterminer donc la nature du contrôle
indépendamment du pays
mais lié bien sûr à la volonté de
poursuivre la modération oui tout à fait
c'est-à-dire que les algorithmes même
effectivement sont agnostiques au sens
où ils sont entraînés les machines
learning étaient entraînée dans toutes
les langues en tout cas dans plus de 10
langues et ensuite la modération humaine
va intervenir aussi dans la langue
appropriée mais c'est peut-être
compliqué parce que quelque chose qui
est
passible de poursuite de la loi
pédophilie accusations ou incitation au
terroristes préférés en français dans un
pays d'Amérique latine ou la législation
est moins dur comment on établit vous
êtes obligé d'identifier quand même la
provenance du message parce que sinon
vous allez censurer quelqu'un au regard
d'une langue mais pas du droit propre au
pays de protection oui c'est une très
bonne question parce que
nous essayons d'avoir des règles les
plus universelles possible mais plus
alors pour certains sujets c'est évident
on n'a pas la pornographie la nudité
l'extrémisme
voilà c'est facile à
établir que ce sont des sujets
universels et par ailleurs nous opérons
évidemment dans le dans le respect des
lois en vigueur dans chaque pays donc
effectivement c'est une considération à
faire mais en tout cas la tendance
globale de la société c'est de Tik Tok
c'est d'avoir l'approche la plus
universelle possible d'appliquer de
manière la plus uniforme possible les
règles de modération et les règles et
d'avoir des mêmes règles communautaires
pour tout le monde
je voudrais je suppose que c'est vous
qui êtes chargé des rapports avec
l'arcom puisque j'ai des rapports
institutionnels et des politiques
publiques c'est de c'est notre petite
équipe oui en charge de cette relation
larcome a publié son rapport 2022 et la
mise à jour assez récemment puisqu'il
s'agit de décembre 2022 donc il y a
quelques mois
c'est pas terrible
je vous lis les points ce qu'ils
appellent les points clés du bilan 2022
déclaration particulièrement précise
avec peu d'informations relatives au
service en France et aucun élément
tangible permettant une évaluation des
moyens mis en place pas de réponse aux
interrogations spécifiques de la com au
mettant ainsi plusieurs enjeux sont trop
étape de l'instruction d'un signalement
fonctionnement des outils de modération
pratique de manipulation identifiée sur
le service etc pas d'éléments chiffrés
relatifs à la France dispositif de
signalement accessible mais peu visible
plusieurs motifs et sous motifs relatifs
à la manipulation de l'information
développement absence d'information
quant aux processus d'évaluation des
algorithmes aucune information sur les
pratiques de manipulation de
l'information identifiée sur le service
et au chapitre des données chiffrées
déclarés nombre de visiteurs uniques par
mois du service en France et dans le
monde non déclaré chiffre d'affaires du
service en France non déclaré effectif
employés aux activités du service en
France non déclaré indicateurs généraux
nombre de contenus identifiés comme
conforta une fausse information non
déclarée parmi ces contenus nombre
détectés automatiquement et la suite de
signalement utilisateurs non déclaré
nombre de contenus comportant une fausse
information qui ont fait l'objet de
mesures non déclarés nombre d'émetteurs
de ces conduits identifiés et par qui a
fait l'objet d'une mesure non déclarée
audience moyenne des contenus identifiés
comme comportant une fausse information
non déclarée
nombre de signalements pour fausse
information par les utilisateurs non
déclarés et les moyens de traitement des
signalements non déclarés nombre de
recours reçu par l'opérateur à l'issue
de la procédure de signalement non
déclaré nombre de comptes détectés
propagent massivement de fausses
informations non déclarées nombre de
faux comptes automatisés détectés non
déclarés nombre de types sur des lequel
des mesures ont été prises non déclarées
vous avez de la chance que l'arcom n'est
pas le droit de
sanctions directement mais c'est
vraiment accablant
il faut dire que ce rapport est
interview de devoir c'est un rapport de
fin 2022 qui est intervenu au moment où
Tik Tok était en train de mettre en
oeuvre de se préparer à la mise en
oeuvre du DSA qui prévoit des
obligations très précises de
transparence et de communication de
données et donc ce travail évidemment
était
prioritaire et par ailleurs c'était la
première fois que nous répondions à ce
rapport donc c'était un premier exercice
sachant que Tik Tok est aussi une
entreprise de mon côté et donc les
données notamment les données pays
à cette époque n'était pas n'était pas
connue ce n'était pas divulgué
aujourd'hui nous sommes quelques mois
plus tard nous avons répondu vol
mentionné tout à l'heure nous avons
répondu au code européen de lutte contre
les informations où nous avons donc
rendu public 2500 données 2500
informations et nous sommes en train de
répondre à la deuxième édition de par
rapport sur pour Arcom et là nous aurons
un niveau de détails beaucoup plus
important donc il est vrai que ce
premier rapport a été jugé
insatisfaisant par la com nous avons eu
l'occasion de dialoguer avec la com nous
avons même accueilli l'arcom à Dublin où
nous avons
organisé des échanges à haut niveau avec
nos responsables de l'équipe 30 safety
pour évoquer la lutte contre des
informations la lutte contre la haine en
ligne la mise en oeuvre du DSA et donc
nous continuons à intensifier cet effort
de transparence comme nous le montrerons
en août prochain au moment où certaines
obligations du DSA s'imposeront à nous
donc on est dans une démarche
d'amélioration permanente de la
transparence nos rapports de la
transparence contiennent beaucoup de
données d'ores et déjà
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
j'en ai terminé avec mes questions moi
j'ai des questions mais sur des sujets
qu'on a déjà évoqué mais je ne voulais
pas interrompre mais mes collègues donc
c'est un peu plus à la fois disparate et
précis il y a quelques mois le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale c'était mu du
fait qu'ils ministre le même déclaré
qu'ils avaient constaté la diffusion
d'éléments de langage diffusé sur les
réseaux sociaux mais notamment sur Tik
Tok pour donner on va dire des éléments
de langage pour défier les règlements
intérieurs des établissements scolaires
notamment sur un sujet qui revient à
l'actualité qui est celui qui est
vestimentaire
ce qui a amené le ministre dans une
formule à déclarer que la République est
je cite plus forte que Tik Tok
c'en est suivi une rencontre
de Tik Tok France et je ne sais pas si
vous en étiez vous avec la ministre
chargée de la jeunesse qui donc nous
savons qu'elle a reçu des représentants
de votre entreprise en 2022 et qu'elle a
appelé voilà guillemets à une viralité
républicaine
je laisse la formule quid depuis il y a
eu des décisions qui ont été prises que
vous avez modifié votre modération sur
le sujet est-ce qu'il y a eu une
modification de l'algorithme quel est
votre opinion sur ce type de sujet merci
monsieur le Président alors
comme la diffusion des valeurs
républicaines
le fait que Tik Tok soit une plateforme
au service évidemment des valeurs de la
République nous avons engagé une
démarche
j'avais presque dire des 2020 des 2021
en tout cas puisque nous avons organisé
des visites en live dans au musée de
l'armée dans le panthéon enfin au
Panthéon également
nous avons accueilli un grand nombre
d'institutions défendant l'histoire et
les valeurs de la République sur notre
plateforme ensuite nous avons avec le
cipdr nous avons accueilli ça veut dire
des comptes ont été créés oui des
comptes ont été créés et nous avons même
organisé une semaine autour des valeurs
de la République notamment de autour de
des valeurs de liberté et d'égalité avec
France Télévisions et et également avec
donc on nous en travaillant avec le
cipdr pour pouvoir
réfléchir ensemble à des
manière de
diffuser ces valeurs sur sur la
plateforme
le CIP le cipdr aussi après la réunion
qui s'est tenue chez le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a été choisie pour
être un relais aussi des
de signalement de vidéos qui pouvaient
effectivement apparaître
faisons
encourageant la désobéissance dans les
établissements scolaires nous avons fait
ce travail d'ailleurs immédiatement de
repérage de ces contenus et de retraits
de ces contenus dès lors qu'ils ont
freinaient c'était ma question voilà
nous l'avons fait nous avons fait ce
travail immédiatement dès que nous avons
dès que nous avons eu connaissance de
ces de ces difficultés et nous avons
connu avec le ministre que s'il y avait
des voilà des informations utiles à nous
faire parvenir que ça prendrait la forme
d'un signalement via le cipdr qui serait
en quelque sorte là aussi un signaler de
confiance donc voilà ça démarche a été
entreprise de manière récente toujours
il y a eu un emballement
[Musique]
nécessaire a été fait ou si vous êtes
comment dire inquiété du fait que que ce
jeune homme pouvait être en danger après
une vidéo qui elle-même émané d'un d'un
une vidéo qui avait fait du tam-tam sur
Tik Tok
je reviendrai vers vous à ce sujet pour
pour vérifier qu'effectivement le
travail a été fait dès que nous avons
des signalements de ce type bien entendu
nous saisissons nos équipes très
Sainte-Sophie qui qui opère les
vérifications et qui le font en
appliquant à la fois le la loi et donc
en France évidemment la loi française et
aussi nos conditions générales
d'utilisation nos règles communautaires
oui parce qu'il est pas interdit d'avoir
une ligne rédactionnelle aussi le manque
vous respectez la loi de se dire qu'il y
a des choses que vous laissez encore
moins passer
vous êtes responsable des affaires
publiques on vous a pas entendu sur le
la ce matin sur ce que vous pensez de la
décision
d'un certain nombre de gouvernements
d'organisations internationales
d'interdire TikTok en France mais pas
seulement mais d'interdire Tik Tok sur
les téléphones des fonctionnaires
à quoi vous attribuez cette décision et
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
mais vous pouvez la voir vous êtes en
dispo alors
sur cette question
c'est venu de la Commission européenne
donc sur les cette D6 cette décision un
petit peu en cascade est arrivée depuis
la Commission européenne et nous avons
évidemment immédiatement réagi puisque
nous ne comprenions pas les raisons de
cette décision
auprès de la Commission européenne voilà
donc il y a une discussion en cours et
je crois pas que jusqu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous ayons eu les éléments
de justification qui avait conduit à
cette décision il y a une discussion en
cours en tout cas nous avons posé la
question parce que nous avons
effectivement eu aucune indication sur
les motifs qui avaient conduit à cette
décision donc ça a été nous avons été
surpris de cette décision et nous
espérons qu'un jour nous aurons la
réponse et entre temps comme vous citer
la France par exemple
le ministre de la Fonction publique a
effectivement pris une décision pour que
les fonctionnaires n'est plus accès aux
applications récréatives au pluriel donc
nous avons estimé que cette décision
était un peu plus fondée dans la mesure
où il n'y avait pas de discrimination
non justifiée à l'égard de Tik Tok par
rapport à d'autres applications
récréatives
ondir sur cette question il y a
quelqu'un qui vous a répondu déjà c'est
le premier ministre belge
Alexander de Crau qui a déclaré au
moment de l'interdiction en Belgique
nous ne devons pas être naïf Tic-Toc est
une entreprise chinoise qui est
aujourd'hui obligée de coopérer avec les
services de renseignement chinois c'est
la réalité donc en Belgique en tout cas
on a l'air d'avoir une opinion précise
là-dessus
en Chine aussi non pas en Chine mais
TikTok je suppose que c'est Tik Tok
caïman a publié un communiqué le 10 mai
dernier c'est peut-être tik Tokyo
non je pense pas en tout cas TikTok un
communiqué expliquant que ces
interdictions sont enracinées dans les
xénophobie
alors laquelle des analyses est-ce que
vous partagez celle de
Premier ministre belge
ou celle du communiqué de Tik Tok et
est-ce que vous pensez aussi que
l'interdiction des gafam en Chine relève
de la xénophobie
monsieur rapporteur bien évidemment je
ne commenterai pas des décisions ou
plutôt des déclarations d'autorité
politiques à fortiori étrangère mais
même française et je vous dis simplement
que la France a pris cette décision qui
semble pour le coup
nous convenir davantage puisqu'il n'y a
pas de discrimination de Tik Tok par
rapport aux autres plateformes et donc
nous ce que nous pensons c'est que
nous sommes une entreprise responsable
qui respecte le droit en vigueur qui met
tout en oeuvre pour protéger l'intégrité
de ces systèmes d'exploitation de sa
plateforme qui a même pris la décision
de construire
je répète encore une fois c'est un
investissement d'un milliard 200
millions d'euros en Europe
des centres de données sécurisées par
des tiers avec des dispositifs de
protection parmi les standards les plus
de sécurité les plus élevés du monde
pour nous mettre à l'abri de tout en
tentative d'ingérence d'intrusion de
manipulation
que nous rendons nos algorithmes les
plus auditables possibles et que nous
prenons toutes ces décisions justement
pour lever les suspicions qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire ne sont pas reposées
sur la moindre preuve c'est tout ce que
je peux dire pour l'instant
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que la
meilleure façon de faire
c'est de couper hermétiquement
les contacts
quel que soit la personne qui s'exprime
madame Fox Monsieur Bertrand vous-même
vous ne nous dites pas on les transfert
de données seront interdits vous nous
dites les transferts de certaines
données ne seront pas l'étanchéaires de
donner non autorisées sur interdits vous
nous dites les transferts seront
minimisés ce qui veut dire en clair ces
transferts continueront avec la Chine
tant que vous aurez tant que vous
n'aurez pas réglé ce problème tant que
vous n'aurez pas appris une décision ce
qui me paraît peut-être compliqué étant
donné
l'ingénierie de l'algorithme et c'est
localisation vous ne convaincre personne
si peut-être vous avez pensé que vous
allez convaincre
est-ce que vous pensez est-ce que vous
pouvez vous engager à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus de transfert de données
avec la Chine je comprends parfaitement
que vous dites que vous dites on peut
pas empêcher les transferts de donner
parce que dans le monde entier puisque
est dans le monde entier et donc il faut
bien que coopérer avec le monde entier
sauf en Chine donc qu'est-ce qui vous
oblige à rester en liaison en transfert
de données avec l'arc sur
comme messagerie etc avec des entités
chinoises dont vous ne donnez pas le nom
puisque encore une fois je vous dis vous
avez déclaré qu'il y avait 20 entités et
vous ne nous
en donnez pas le comment voulez-vous
qu'il y ait pas de suspicion qui
continue
dans la mesure ce rapporteur où il y
aurait ce système insularisé en Europe
avec des données qui sont conservées
dans une enclave avec un tiers de
confiance extérieur au groupe by band
l'entreprise européenne
qui puisse tracer tous les accès et qui
puisse vérifier la justification de
chaque accès à chaque donnée
honnêtement je ne vois pas ce qui peut y
avoir de plus fort comme garantie donnée
gouvernement français aux autorités de
régulation
que les données des Européens
seront pleinement protégés
et je ne connais pas d'autres
entreprises
d'autres plateformes
qui est pris un engagement similaire à
celui que nous avons pris
donc quand vous parlez d'insularité vous
voulez dire qu'il n'y aura plus de
transfert de données avec la Chine j'ai
ajouté que chaque accès de chaque
personne à chaque donnée serait tracé et
devrait être justifié pour des raisons
d'opération du service donc il y aura
encore transfert de données avec la
Chine je peux pas préjugé de l'évolution
de la société c'est simplement ce que je
vous dis c'est actuellement
c'est l'engagement qui a été pris qui
est un engagement très fort très
substantiel y compris dans le volume des
investissements qui qui sont en train
d'être réalisés avec un délai que
j'indiquais 15 mois qui est un délai
très ambitieux
sur cette question j'aurais voulu vous
permettre de d'affirmer de confirmer des
faits sur lesquels vous n'avez pas
souhaité
répondre ou réagir dans le travail
journalistique dont je parlais des
anciens salariés ont été interrogés je
vais vous donner lecture certains termes
reviennent souvent pudiquement dans la
bouche des anciens salariés le fait que
la culture d'entreprise serait très
chinoise jusque là rien de grave on a
des entreprises en France ou c'est très
américain jusqu'à la caricature des
conseils d'administration mais néanmoins
c'est ce qui est d'une entreprise serait
très chinoise par exemple comprendre
particulièrement énergivore mais aussi
procédurières et secrète j'ouvre les
guillemets je faisais partie d'un comité
sans cesse pencher sur les conditions de
travail des salariés sur leur équilibre
vie professionnelle vie personnelle
raconte un ancien salarié américain pour
étayer notre travail nous avons fait
passer un questionnaire aux salariés
pour comprendre leur état d'esprit sauf
que nous n'avons pas eu accès aux
données brutes elles ont été directement
prises en par nos collègues chinois et
nous sont revenus entre guillemets
traités fin de citation tous les
salariés de confirment si Tik Tok
s'étend à travers le monde le lieu de
prise de décision reste bien la Chine
ils doivent maintenir un équilibre
précaire au quotidien ils sont en
permanence c'est le point sur lequel je
voulais arriver au quotidien ils sont en
permanence en contact avec les employés
chinois de by dance qui joue un rôle clé
dans la validation des projets et des
procédures un système tellement
procédurier qu'il a tendance à ralentir
les prises de décision regrette
plusieurs anciens salariés parallèlement
certains ont été briefés donc c'est ma
deuxième question la première elle pose
sur le fait de savoir vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure il y a pas de lien au
quotidien avec des personnes travaillant
pour bikdence en Chine donc je vous
repose la question et si je vous demande
si vous voulez infirmer ce qui est dit
dans ce travail journalistique deuxième
point parallèlement certains ont été
entre guillemets briefés sur la manière
dont ils doivent parler de l'entreprise
en public c'est votre fonction raison
pour laquelle je vous pose la question
selon des informations du
média spécialisé guizmodo
note de bas de page sollicité concernant
l'actualité de ce document TikTok France
n'a pas donné de réponse l'un des
principaux commandements promus par le
document et de contester les liens
qu'entretient Tik Tok en Europe avec sa
maison mère en Chine ouvrez les
guillemets minimiser bike dance
minimiser l'association avec la Chine
minimiser l'intelligence artificielle
sans se demande pourquoi font ainsi
textuellement partie des éléments à
retenir de ce document celui-ci propose
par ailleurs certains éléments de
langage clé en main comme ouvrez les
guillemets il y a beaucoup de
désinformations autour de Tik Tok en ce
moment la réalité c'est que Tik Tok
n'est même pas disponible en Chine
fermer les guillemets
quel est votre point de vue là-dessus là
on est vraiment dans votre domaine
est-ce que je peux me permettre monsieur
le Président de vous demander quelle
année remonte le premier commentaire que
vous avez fait c'est les salariés qui
parlent de quelle année il s'agissait-il
oui bien sûr alors vous auriez pu le
demander par écrit si vous avez voulu
d'ailleurs à la journaliste qui qui vous
a interrompu qui dit vous avoir
interrogé ne pas avoir une réponse mais
je vous dirais bien quelle année peu
importe
parce qu'en fait je vous le préciserai
par écrit parce que parce que en fait là
en tout cas il est paru au mois de mars
non plus parce que sinon il faudra aussi
on a des modérateurs
personne
minimiser le fait que l'origine de
l'entreprise est en Chine l'origine de
l'entreprise donc je parle du groupe
binance
mais c'est une entreprise qui ensuite
généré Tik Tok et Tik Tok qui s'est
dévoué
extrêmement rapidement et donc en fait
certaines choses qui ont pu être dites
certaines années de qui paraissent
peut-être proches mais qui sont réalités
très lointaines dans l'histoire du
groupe ne correspondent absolument pas à
la réalité que moi je peux confirme pas
ne correspond pas à la réalité ce que
vous vivez absolument pas ou de ce que
vivant
est
européen donc voilà beaucoup de
décisions sont prises au niveau européen
mon responsable hiérarchique est à
Londres au niveau de l'Irlande
s'agissant de trust and safety
et ensuite vous avez le SIO qui est à
Singapour la directrice générale des
opérations qui est à Los Angeles
la culture d'entreprise est très
mélangée voilà c'est ça ce que elle est
quand même très anglo-saxonne mais elle
est très mélangée nous on a pression que
chaque continent a apporte sa propre
couleur à l'entreprise c'est pas une
entreprise monocolor c'est une
entreprise vraiment
multiculturelle moi c'est ce que je
ressens et
j'ai pu voir même en arrivant en 2020 et
maintenant en 2023 déjà en 2020 le
management était très
gouverné au niveau européen et
aujourd'hui
il est très aussi collaboratif
également au niveau européen
je n'ai pas rebondi tout à l'heure
mais sur le vos fonctions antérieures ou
avant d'arriver chez Tik Tok est-ce que
comme c'était évoqué dans la presse vous
confirmez vous infirmer avoir été
recruté par News Republic
alors News Republic a été le premier
bureau de représentation si on peut dire
de Tik Tok en France avant la création
de la filiale oui voilà donc en fait
c'est c'est Tik Tok SAS a pris la suite
d'accord et donc les contrats ont été
transférés ensuite vous êtes à partir de
quand avez-vous travaillé à nous serez
public bah c'était le 7 septembre 2020
2020 oui donc c'est la même c'est la
même voilà c'est la même entreprise on
peut dire public existe toujours tout ça
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas sûr mais
je n'ai pas d'information précise
toujours déclaré avec Madame
comme présidente et comme directeur
Monsieur djao Lyon
j'aurais aimé savoir si c'est le mari de
Madame
Sao Tian ou pas
j'en ai quasiment terminé simplement en
fait ce que je veux c'est vous donner la
possibilité de répondre ce qui dit dans
la presse et sur quoi vous n'avez pas
répondu
sur un article
récent dans les comment vous fonctionnez
en termes de partenariat pour le dire
autrement est-ce que vous ne les
partenariats d'influence avec des
personnalités
identifiées dans le grand public par
exemple sur les questions de livres
êtes-vous engagé dans une relation
commerciale avec des journalistes
travaillant sur le service public
alors là pas du tout à mon niveau ça
c'est certain et je ne pense pas non
plus que ce soit le cas la direction des
contenus des opérations ça je pense que
ma collègue pourra vous en dire plus
mais
ce qui se passe c'est que il y a des
créateurs qui ouvrent des comptes sur
Tik Tok pour apporter des contenus
et que il peut y avoir éventuellement
une un accompagnement dans la dans le
développement de ces comptes mais ce
n’aurait pas des partenariats
des ménages pour des journalistes qui ça
se fait encore aujourd'hui après on
apprécie ça de la manière qu'on veut
mais ça existe un journaliste
identifié à animer un congrès de
chirurgien-dentiste je ne sais où parce
que c'est une tête connue à la télé et
on se paye le journaliste est-ce que Tik
Tok a ce genre de partenariat avec des
journalistes qui en étant sur Tik Tok
son par ailleurs rémunérés par Tik Tok
d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est sûr que ce n'est absolument pas le
genre de choses que nous pratiquons
d'accord ça c'est certain ensuite ma
collègue pourra vous dire de la manière
dont les créateurs sont accompagnés
les publics figures comme on dit peuvent
être accompagnés mais ce n'est d'accord
à mon sens ça ne rentre pas dans ce type
de montage que vous évoquez
il y a pas d'autres questions alors moi
j'en ai terminé également simplement
comme vous le savez enfin vous avez
souvent eu l'occasion de préciser que
vous étiez une entreprise jeune et que
ça pouvait expliquer par ailleurs le
fait que vous apprenez à
rendre certains rapports vous confirmer
à certaines obligations nous nous sommes
une commission d'enquête jeune mais qui
n'a pas le temps vieillir par définition
puisque nous sommes là pour 6 mois donc
nous avons un délai que vous connaissez
parfaitement vous avez souvent évoqué
comment les choses fonctionnent en
cascade dans votre entreprise ben nous
en cascade c'est pareil c'est-à-dire
qu'à partir du moment on a fini les
auditions on a un rapport à rédiger on a
un délai donc l'ensemble des éléments
que vous avez suggéré de nous adresser
par écrit je vous serez reconnaissante
bien vouloir nous les adresser
rapidement parce que vous savez quels
sont nos délais je pense qu'une je pense
qu'un délai d'huit jours nous obligerait
sans quoi si on n'a pas les réponses et
on a on doit cette obligation aux
personnes que nous représentons aussi
je voudrais pas me trouver à devoir
refaire une audition voilà pour dire les
choses souhaitez-vous rajouter quelque
chose maintenant que nous avons nous
terminer nos questions
je souhaite simplement vous remercier
pour pour votre écoute et de
l'opportunité qui nous a été offerte de
pouvoir échanger sur vos sujets de
préoccupation légitime et donc j'espère
que nous avons pu apporter déjà
suffisamment de d'éléments y compris
pour pour assurer la représentation
nationale sur des préoccupations qui
sont encore une fois parfaitement
légitimes et pour lesquelles nous
pensons apporter des réponses à la
hauteur de ces de ces enjeux voilà donc
nous vous remercions merci Monsieur
Merci